GOVERNMENT COMMITTEES HEARING
WE ARE CONTINUING TO PRACTICE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THE MASS BE WARNED AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY
EVERYONE PRESENT HERE IN THE
ROOM FOR THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK
WOULD BE GLADLY TO HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO VOTE PROVIDE ONE FOR
YOU. WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES TODAY
TODAY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO.
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF.
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN APPROPRIATE SPACING.
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITOL. FOR THOSE HERE IN THE
ROOM. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
LISTEN FOR MY PRODUCT TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. YOU CAN
EXPECT THAT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING. OR
RETURN YOUR SEATS PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. WE'LL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL THE
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE SCUSE ME ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
LOCAL ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOUR TESTIFYING BEGINS THEIR
TRIP PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE. HELLO
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE.
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST FOR YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THAT SOUND
DISTORTION. IS ALSO BE ADVISED
IF YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL YOUR REMAIN ON
A LIFELINE I WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEM WITH THE MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICES YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE FIVE
EIGHT. AND MY STUFF WILL BE
THERE TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ARE SPECIFIC
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE CONTINUE USING
METHODS TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE STILL
FACE. NOW LET'S COVER THE
GROUND RULES FOR APPROPRIATE
CONDUCT. THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE
EMPLOYER PROCEEDINGS IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE C. FORMA CONDUCT OF
HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE REMOVING A
MASK AND REFUSING TO PUT IT
BACK ON. TALKING ARE MAKING
LOUD NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE.
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE SPEAKING
LONGER THAN THE TIME ALLOTTED.
EXTEND DISCUSSION ON MATTERS
NOT RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF
THE HEARING OR BILL. OR ANY
OTHER DESTRUCTIVE ACTS. TO
ADDRESS ANY DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT
I WILL TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS.
IF IT INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR
HEARING PROCESS I WOULD DIRECT
THEM TO STOP AND WARNED THEM
THAT THE CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS
MAY RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE
NATURE OF THE DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT AND I MAY TEMPER LET
TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF THE CONDUCT DOES
NOT STOP I REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS AND
ESCORTING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. WE HAVE
TWELVE ITEMS TODAY ON THE
AGENDA ONE OF THOSE ITEMS IS
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE. AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY ONE BY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. IN
ADDITION ONE ITEM HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. AB FIVE SEVEN
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GALLAGHER. WE'LL HEAR ALL BILLS
IN THE ORDER SHOWN ON THE
AGENDA UNLESS OTHERWISE NOTED.
WE'LL TAKE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PREACH BILL. THIS WITNESSES
WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES EACH TO
PROVIDE THEI TESTIMONY ALL
SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THE POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION MAY PROVIDE. A
TESTIMONY IN ANY ORDER. LET'S
SEE WE DON'T HAVE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. ONE TWO THREE. YES OKAY
IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A QUORUM
THE SECRETARY. CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HERE RIGHT HELLO.
BOERNER HORVATH WELL HOW TO GET
TRANSIT RAMOS. RAMOS PRESIDENT
ROOSEVELT THIS IS RIVAS
PRESIDENT ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL
YOU VOEPEL PRESIDENT. YOU FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A QUORUM
WE'RE GOING TO START I DON'T
SEE OUR FIRST SPEAKER HERE I'D
LIKE TO SPEAK WITH THE START
WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SEVEN
TWELVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON.
WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE. OKAY I'D
LIKE TO FIRST START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE%
AMENDMENTS AND I THINK THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND
SPONSORS FOR THE- SEVERAL
MONTHS. EIGHTY SEVEN TWELVE
AUTHORIZES AN INCREASE ON THE
LIMITS OF DELEGATED L. A.
COUNTY AUTHORITY CAN APPROVE
FOR PUBLIC CONTRACT CHANGE
ORDERS FOR ADDITIONS ON LARGE
SCALE PUBLIC. WORKS PROJECTS
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO APPROVE
CHANGE ORDERS AND CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTS BY FOR FIFTH VOTE.
TAKES IMMEDIATE THE PROCESS THE
BOARD MAY DESIGNATE A THIRTY TO
A COUNTY ENGINEER OFFICER TO
ORDER AND APPROVED CHANGES TO
AN ORIGINAL CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACT UP. UNTIL CERTAIN
LIMITS THESE LIMITS HAVE NOT
BEEN UPDATED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN AND DO NOT REFLECT
INFLATION CHANGES IN
CONSTRUCTION MARKET PRICING AND
CHANGES IN THE SCALE OF
PROJECTS. THIS RESULTS IN
CHANGE ORDER LIMITS FREQUENTLY
B REACHED OFTEN LEADING TO
COSTLY DELAYS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR L. A.
COUNTY WITH THEIR CURRENT
PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTS. THE
COUNTY ALSO HAS SEVERAL COUNTY
PROJECTS IN THE PIPELINE WITH
INITIAL CONTRACT COST REGION
FROM TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO ONE
POINT TWO BILLION. EIGHTY SEVEN
TWELVE SIXTY DECREASE DELAYS
AND HELP EXPIATE L. A. COUNTY
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS SUCH AS
MEDICAL CENTERS AND BRIDGES.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
REMOTELY BY PHONE IS STEVE
BERGER FROM L. A. COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC WORKS.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER-
OPERATOR WHO ARE LOOKING FOR
STEVE BERGER. THE MURDER HERE.
YES. OKAY BOB SO AB MANAGER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS STEVE BERGER AND I'M
AN ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY PUBLIC
WORKS I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORTING SUPPORTING ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN TWELVE. AT THE COST
OF CONSTRUCTION IS INCREASED
OVER THE LAST DECADE WITHOUT A
CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN
DELEGATED AUTHORITY COULD
CHANGE ORDERS. WE'RE FINDING
THAT THE NEED TO GO TO THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
APPROVAL OF THE CHANGE ORDERS
IS INCREASING. IN ADDITION HE'S
CURRENTLY WORKING TO DELIVER
MANY LARGE PROJECTS IN WHICH
THE NEED FOR CORRESPONDING
INCREASE IN CHANGE ORDER
AUTHORITY IS NEEDED TO ALLOW US
TO KEEP PROJECTS ON TRACK. AND
AVOID COSTLY DELAYS. BY
PROVIDING INCREASES IN A
TORTILLA ON A LIMITED NUMBER OF
HIGH VALUE PROJECTS. THIS BILL
WILL HELP KEEP THE PROCESS
STREAMLINED AND ALLOW US TO
DELIVER IMPORTANT PROJECTS COST
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HAPPY HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE GALLERY.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
OTHERS ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. SEVEN TWELVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE ONE COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. IN THE LINE OF FIFTY
EIGHT- MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRIAN STICKER ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN TWELVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MANY
OTHERS OPERATOR. AND MADAM
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE GALLERY SAYING NONE
OPERATOR THERE ANY ANY IN
OPPOSITION PRE BE SEVEN TWELVE.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION AB
SEVENTY WHILE THE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE WE HAVE
A MOTION- BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS AND PUNCHES ME FOR OUR
FRONT AND THEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU GOT THIS AMER'S. OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ANNA FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
AND ALLOW US TO REVIEW ITS
EXPANSION LA COUNTY'S.
DELEGATED AUTHORITY FOR CHANGE
ORDERS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
LEARNING HOW THIS ALL WORKS FOR
YOU AND HOW IT IS IN PRACTICE
AND WE- WILL LOOK TO CONTINUE
TO COLLABORATE WITH YOU ON THE
ISSUE IN THE FUTURE. I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I.
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
AYE BOERNER HORVATH. BUT I
RAMOS. ALMOST FIVE. THREE OF US
SIDE ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL RIGHT HI EIGHT
ZERO HOW GREAT HERE THAT BILLS
OUT AND THANK. YOU VERY MUCH I
THINK ABOUT A MEASURE. OKAY
WELL WE'LL GO TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB TEN NINETY ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN WE HAVE TO FOR
SUPPORT AND TO FOR OPPOSITION
FOR THIS- OF THE- PROCEED SIR
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. AB TEN NINETY ONE
WOULD REFORM THE GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE OF THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS VTA. MEDIA'S
GOVERNANCE HAS BEEN THE SUBJECT
OF THREE CIVIL GRAND JURY
REPORTS OVER THE LAST SEVENTEEN
YEARS IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR. TWO
THOUSAND NINE AND TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN CIVIL GRAND JURY
HIGHLIGHTED THE VT IS OPERATING
PERFORMANCE HAS CONTINUED TO
DETERIORATE OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS. RELATIVE TO ITS OWN
HISTORICAL PERFORMANCE AND THE
PERFORMANCE OF YOUR AGENCIES.
ACROSS A WIDE VARIETY OF
METRICS. OF THE TWO THOUSAND
FOUR IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
GRAND JURY REACHED THE SAME
CONCLUSION. MEDIA'S GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE IS A ROOT CAUSE OF
THE AGENCIES POOR PERFORMANCE.
HISTORICALLY THE BOARD HAS
SUFFERED FROM A LACK OF FOCUS A
LACK OF CONTINUITY AND A LACK
OF RELEVANT EXPERIENCE. ALMOST
HALF OF THE BOARD IS MADE UP OF
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO
LIKE I DID WHEN I SERVED ON THE
POLITICAL SOUL. ARE WORKING
FULL TIME. SPENDING TWENTY PLUS
HOURS A WEEK ON COUNCIL DUTIES
ARE POINTED TO A HALF DOZEN
OTHER BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS.
AND DON'T HAVE STAFF TO HELP
THEM READ THROUGH HUNDREDS OF
PAGES OF MATERIAL. TO BE
SUFFICIENTLY PREPARED FOR
MEETINGS. IN ADDITION MEMBERS
ARE ONLY APPOINTED FOR A TWO
YEAR TERM FOR AN AGENCY WITH A
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET. BY
THE TIME BOARD MEMBERS KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING THEY'RE OFF
THE BOARD. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
TRUE FOR THE SMALLER CITIES.
AND THE GRAND JURY REPORTS HAVE
NOTED THAT MANY BOARD MEMBERS
DO NOT HAVE THE REQUISITE
EXPERIENCE. THE GOVERNOR
TRANSIT AGENCY. THE GRAND JURY
INSTRUCTED VTA TO PROPOSE
LEGISLATION TO RESTRUCTURE THE
GOVERNING BOARD WHICH IS
ENSHRINED IN STATE LAW. I WROTE
AB TEN NINETY ONE WITH THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN MIND. AT A
HIGH LEVEL THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE APPOINTING
AUTHORITIES TO ENSURE THAT
EXPERTISE. RELATIVE TO
TRANSPORTATION. INFRASTRUCTURE
OR PROJECT MANAGEMENT
ACCOUNTING OR FINANCE AND
EXECUTIVE MANAGEMENT. ARE
REPRESENTED ON THE BOARD. IT
WOULD EXPAND THE TERMS ON THE
BOARD FROM TWO YEARS TO FOUR
YEARS FOR GREATER CONTINUITY.
IT WOULD REDUCE THE OVERALL
BOARD SIZE FROM EIGHTEEN
MEMBERS TO NINE VOTING MEMBERS.
AND IT WOULD REPLACE THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS ON THE BOARD
WITH QUALIFIED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. WHILE THE BILL. WELL
THE BILL REDUCES THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF BOARD MEMBERS
APPOINTED BY SAN JOSE IN BY THE
NON SAN JOSE CITIES. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
BILL MAINTAINS THE CURRENT
BALANCE BETWEEN THESE TWO
GROUPS. IT DOES NOT TAKE POWER
AWAY FROM SAN JOSE AND GIVE
MORE POWER. TO THE SMALLER
CITIES OR VICE VERSA. HOWEVER
THE BILL INCREASES THE NUMBER
OF MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS EACH
SUPERVISOR WOULD APPOINT ONE
DIRECTOR. THIS WAS DONE WITH
THE HOPE. THAT BOARD MEMBERS
WILL ACT MORE REGIONALLY AND
LESSEN THE PAROCHIAL BEST
INTEREST OF THE INDIVIDUAL CITY
THEY REPRESENT. I'VE HAD MORE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS BILL
AT THIS STAGE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAN ANY OF
THE HUNDRED PLUS BILLS. I HAVE
INTRODUCED IN MY FIVE YEARS IN
THE ASSEMBLY. AND I'VE BEEN
VERY UP FRONT WITH EVERYONE
THAT THIS BILL IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS. I RECEIVED A LOT OF
GOOD CONSTRUCTIVE FEEDBACK OVER
THE LAST FEW MONTHS. BUT WE
CAN'T CONTINUE TO IGNORE THE
STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS WITH THE
VTA BOARD THAT HAVE BEEN
EMPHASIZED. BY THREE CIVIL
GRAND JURY REPORTS. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. AND ACT LIKE THE
EXISTING STRUCTURE IS THE ONLY
POSSIBLE OPTION FOR ETA. MEDIA
WRITERS STAFF IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY TAXPAYERS DESERVE. A
MORE ENGAGED AND MORE
EXPERIENCED BOARD. SHOULD THE
BILL MOVE OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS. ESPECIALLY
THE OPPONENTS. TO IDENTIFY
AREAS OF COMPROMISE TO ENSURE
THAT B. T. A. HAS ENGAGED AN
EXPERIENCED BOARD THAT EVERYONE
DESERVES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON A. B. TEN
NINETY ONE. AND WITH ME I HAVE
THREE SO NEIL WHO IS THE FORMER
CHAIR OF VTA. AND COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF SANTA
CLARA. AND JOHN MCALLISTER
FORMER MOUNTAIN VIEW MAYOR AND
CHAIR OF THE VTA. AD HOC BOARD
ENHANCEMENT COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR OF
PLEASE THE HE HAD INCREASE
O'NEILL. ALL WITNESS LINES ARE
OPEN. THANK YOU SHARE ALL THEIR
CURRY BIKESHARE LACKEY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN BILL
EIGHTY TEN NINETY ONE I WAS A
MEMBER OF THE VTA BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY ALTHOUGH I HAD
THE HONOR OF SERVING AS CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR OF THE BOARD AT
THE MEETING WHERE I WAS
INSTALLED AS CHAIR IN TWENTY
NINETEEN I MADE SOME FRANK
REMARKS ABOUT THE CASE
CHALLENGES. THE BIGGEST ONE
WHAT THE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
THE BOARD I ASKED THE BOARD TO
WORK WITH ME TO DESIGN A
STRONGER BOARD WONDER CAN FOCUS
ON THE TREMENDOUS
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES AND SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND OUR REGION I
CONVENE AN AD HOC BOARD
COMMITTEE TO EXAMINE THE SOURCE
OF THE PROBLEM AND FIND A
BETTER WAY FORWARD WE DEVELOPED
A ROBUST FLIPBOARD ISSUES
ENGAGED OUR OUTSIDE AUDITOR
GENERAL TO HELP ANALYZE THEM.
WE BOARD STRUCTURE THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES AROUND
THE U. S. DURING MY ATTENDANCE
AT TRANSPORTATION CONFERENCES I
FOUND VERY FEW SUCCESSFUL
AGENCIES HAD BGH BOARD
STRUCTURE. THE RESULTING REPORT
DIDN'T MAKE A RECOMMENDATION ON
CHANGING THE BOARD STRUCTURE.
AS THE AUDITOR GENERAL FELT THE
DTA HAD SO MANY ISSUES. BUT
THEY WEREN'T SURE PUTTING A NEW
BOARD STRUCTURE IN PLACE WOULD
HELP. THE AD HOC COMMITTEE
COULDN'T REACH A CONSENSUS ON
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BOARD ON
AN ALTERNATIVE STRUCTURE. I
BELIEVE THE AD HOC COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WERE CONCERNED ABOUT A
POLITICAL PATH FORWARD. I STILL
AM CONVINCED THE VTA AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY. THE PEOPLE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WOULD BENEFIT FROM
A BOARD STRUCTURES SUCH AS
THOSE DESCRIBED IN AB TEN
NINETY ONE. WITH THE SCOPE OF
VGH RESPONSIBILITIES AND IS
VERY LARGE BUDGET. WE NEED ONE
VERY FOCUSED ON BTA. NOT HAVING
BTA IS ONE OF MANY ANCILLARY
DUTIES. FOR MY FIRST BOARD
MEETING AT VGH CHAIR I WORK
WITH STAFF TO PLACE FOR MEMBERS
ON THE MANY VGA COMMITTEE. WHEN
I ARRIVED FOR THE MEETING I
STARTED. HEARING WHICH OF THE
SITTING BOARD MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
REMOVED FROM VTA BY THEIR
MAYORS. THESE INCLUDED BOARD
MEMBERS WHO ARE GOING TO CHAIR
COMMITTEES. ONE OF THE MAYORS
WHO HAD NO EXPERIENCE A VGA OR-TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS. PUT
HIMSELF ON THE BOARD AND HE WAS
PLANNING TO RUN FOR ANOTHER
OFFICE THAT YEAR. LATER THAT
YEAR HE RESIGNED FROM VGA INPUT
THE PRIOR BOARD MEMBER BACK ON.
A COUPLE OTHER BOARD MEMBERS
GOT TEXT MESSAGES DURING THE
MEETING SAYING THEY WERE BEING
ON APPOINTED ONE LEANED OVER
AND SAID TO ME. HOW LONG IT'S
BEEN GREAT TO WORK WITH YOU AND
HE STARTED TO PACK UP HIS
THINGS. I SAID TO HIM WHERE ARE
YOU GOING. HE SHOWED ME HIS
PHONE WITH A TEXT AND SAID
HOME. I DID SAID YOU CAN'T
LEAVE NOW I NEED YOUR
PRECOCIOUS SHIN. AND HE WAS A
STRONG VOICE IN NEED OF A
QUORUM. I CONVINCE HIM TO STAY
FOR PARTICLE SESSION BUT OTHERS
LEFT. THE STORY REFLECTS AN
ONGOING ISSUE WITH VTA BOARD. I
DON'T MEAN TO BE CRITICAL OF
THE BOARD MEMBERS BUT THEY ARE
EITHER FULL TIME COUNCIL
MEMBERS ARE COUNTY SUPERVISORS.
OR OR PART TIME COUNCIL MEMBERS
USUALLY HAVE DAY JOBS AND IT'S
VERY CHALLENGING FOR THEM TO
GIVE VTA. THE APPROPRIATE TIME
ATTENTION. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SENDING THEM BERMAN AB
TEN NINETY ONE TO PROVIDE.
BEACHY WITH THE BOARD. TO
PROVIDING THE BEST. WHICH FOR
SO VALLEY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MISS
O'NEILL NOW LOOKING FOR JOHN
MCALLISTER PLEASE. I'M HERE.
CAN I GO AHEAD YES YOU CAN.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO BE A WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. WHEN I WAS ON THE
BOARD FOR THREE YEARS AS A
BOARD MEMBER AND ALSO FOR YEARS
ON THE PUBLIC ADVISORY BOARD I
DON'T A LOT OF. INCONSISTENCIES
AND- CANTICUM PARTICLE. YEAH
COMMITTEE. CANTOR APPROACH
WHICHEVER I NEED HELP AND AFTER
WEEKS. FIND SOME WAY TO WE CAN
LOOK AT THIS AND TRY TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO MAKE THE SYSTEM
WORK BETTER NOW AS YOU HEARD
EARLIER THERE WAS BIG. PUBLIC
COMMENTS ABOUT. THE REPORT THAT
WE GOT FROM. IT CONSULTANT AND
IT IS TRUE THAT WE NEVER CAME
UP BUT THEY NEVER CAME UP WITH
A RECOMMENDATION ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER ABOUT POOR GOVERNANCE.
BUT WHAT THAT GIVEN. WE AS A
BOARD THAT WE DON'T HAVE POWER
TO CHANGE HOW PEOPLE ARE POINT
BUT WE DO HAVE CONTROL OUR OVER
OUR MEMBERS ARE APPOINTED. OUR
APPOINTED WE FIGURE LET'S LOOK
AT THE SELECTION PROCESS SO
THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE. ON THE BOARD
ARE ENGAGED AND INFORMED. SO.
BY GOING TO THE THERE ARE THREE
AREAS THAT WERE IMPORTANT TO ME
THAT I FIGURED THAT THE BOARD
COULD ACTION ADNOC COMMITTEE
COULD ACTUALLY WORK ON TO
IMPROVE THE ENGAGEMENT ONE WITH
ENGAGEMENT WELL WITH THE
APPOINTMENT PROFIT. AND ONE
WITH THE PAROCHIAL ATTITUDE.
THE BOARD OF NEEDED FOR US-
STAFF USUALLY PUTS OUT ABOUT
TEN MAJOR POLICY DOCUMENT
STRATEGIC PLANS CONGESTION
MANAGEMENT PLAN. THEY SIMPLY AT
TWO THOUSAND FOUR. IT CAME TO
MY ATTENTION THAT A LOT OF THE
BOARD MEMBERS NEVER FULLY READ
ANY OF THE INFORMATION OR
ENTITIES POLICY REPORT AND WHAT
WAS THAT CONCERNED ME WAS THAT
THESE WERE THE BASIS. FOR AND
THE BACKGROUND TO MAKE MAJOR
DECISIONS. TALKING ABOUT A-
ORGANIZATION THAT DOES. HAVE A
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET WORK. NINE
DOLLARS IN CAPITAL PROJECTS AND
YET PEOPLE ARE MAKING DECISIONS
WITHOUT FULLY READING THE
POLICIES THAT THEY ARE SUPPOSED
TO FOLLOW. WE WOULD HAVE PEOPLE
AT THE BOARD LEAVE AT EIGHT
O'CLOCK EVEN THOUGH THE BOARD
MEETINGS WILL CONTINUE PAST
NINE OR PEOPLE WERE SAT THERE
VERY QUIETLY. SO THAT WAS
REALLY CONCERNING TO ME HOW CAN
YOU GAUGE THEIR GATE. ANOTHER
CONCERN WHAT THE APPOINTMENT.
AND PEOPLE ARE SAYING WELL WE
HAVE TO HAVE THIS EVERYBODY IS
APPOINTED TO THAT BOARD EXCEPT
THE MAYOR SENATE THANK YOU
POINTS PEOPLE. SO IN THAT
APPOINTMENT AS- ADAM NEIL SAID
IF THE POLITICAL PROCESS AND
YET AT THE WHIM OF A CERTAIN
AIR SPECIALIST WILL POINT OUT
THEY COME AND THEY GO AND SO
THERE WAS ALWAYS CONCERN ALSO
THE TIMING OF THE TWO YEAR
ELECTION NEVER TIDY AND ALWAYS
WITH THE ELECTION OF THAT
INDIVIDUAL THEY MAY HAVE BEEN
ELECTED TO SERVE AND POINTED TO
THE TWO YEAR TERM. BUT ONLY
SPEND ONE TIME. SO THAT WAS
ALWAYS A PROBLEM TO WITH THE
INTO THE ELECTIONS. LITTLE
BLANK DISCOUNT. AND THEN THE
FINAL THING KILLED ADDED TO.
EVERYBODY WHEN THEY ON AND WAS
RE MANY TIMES REGIONAL REDUCE
YOUR RESPONSIBILITY BUT THERE
ARE MANY INSTANCES ONCE THE
SENATE WHEN THERE IS A GROUP OF
EACH CANDIDATE ALONG WITH TWO
BOARD MEMBERS FROM. BY THE
STATE OF FOR MAJORITY. PLEASE
WRAP IT UP MISTER MCALLISTER
REFER. OKAY SO YEAH BASICALLY
SO WHAT WAS HAPPENING A LOT OF
TIMES WHEN MONEY WAS BEING
ALLOCATED A MEASURE WE COMING
FROM THE FROM THE BOARD THE
MOTION WOULD BE MADE
IMMEDIATELY NO DISCUSSION AND
WE GO RIGHT INTO A VOTE. AND SO
WE NEED PEOPLE TO START LOOKING
AT PEARL COULD NOT PAROCHIAL
BUT LOOK AT A REGIONAL THINK
AND WITH MR BERMAN BILL THAT
WILL ALLOW THE TAKE THE
APPROPRIATE APPROACH AND GET
BACK TO WHAT PTA REALLY IF IT'S
A REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY. AND NOT SOMEBODY'S
BACKYARD TRANSPLANT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR MCALLISTER- ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. I DON'T SEE ANY IT
HERE IN THE GALLERY. ARE THERE
ANY ONLINE OPERATOR. THIS IS AB
TEN NINETY ONE I'M LOOKING FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. TEN NINETY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. I CANNOT
LINE SIXTY FOUR YEAR MIKE IS UP.
THANK YOU ZACH BUILDING GEHRY
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AN ONLINE AT YOUR
MIKE IS OPEN. AT LAKE FOUNDER
AND CEO OF SILICON VALLEY
TRYING TO USERS SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND. FORTY ONE. FIND FORTY
ONE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY. DAVID
SCHOEN BROWN PRESIDENT OF THE-
TRAIN RIDERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO PRESIDENT
OF TRANS STAFF BOTH
ORGANISATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND ONCE
AGAIN WE GOTTA LINE. FORTY ONE.
FOUNDED HIS ROLE UNDER BRAND
AND SAN JOSE A STRONG SUPPORT
WE GET THAT MISSION I LIKE TO
GIVE YOU A QUICK TWO QUICK
EXAMPLES OF THE COLLATERAL
DAMAGE COSTA RICAN OPERATOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND MADAM
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE VERY WERE NOW
LOOKING FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I HAVE TO- AND GLENN
HENDRIX AS WELL AS- MR THE VICE
MAYOR JONES AS SOON AS A. THIS
IS GOING ON HERE. GOOD WELCOME.
ONE LOOK CHUCK PERSON AUG YOUR
CURRY VICE CHAIR LACKEY AND
MEMBERS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HEARING
OR TESTIMONY THIS AFTERNOON I'M
GOING TEMPERATURE OF DJ
BOARDING VICE MAYOR OF THE CITY
CENTRE BELL ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FOUR. THE LEGISLATIVE CHANGE
PROPOSED BY AB TEN NINETY ONE
IS UNNECESSARY WILL DO SERIOUS
HARM TO BJ'S OPERATIONAL
CONTINUED SUCCESS. THE CURRENT
BOARD WHICH SAYS APPOINT BY
EACH SO. AND SO AS YET UNNAMED
TO SELECT CITY REPRESENTATION.
THE CURRENT REPRESENTATION ON
THE GT FORTY STRUCTURES
REPRESENTS A CAREFUL BALANCE
BETWEEN POPULATION AND REGIONAL
DIFFERENCES. WELL NO SYSTEM OF
REPRESENTATION IS PERFECT THIS
BALANCES WORKS EXCEPTIONALLY IN
PAST INTEREST OF THE PEOPLE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN OUR
REGION. CRITICISMS OF THE CHAIR
ALWAYS TAKEN SERIOUSLY AND WERE
JUSTIFIED ACTED UPON. OR BOARD
OF DIRECTORS CONSIST OF LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS FROM THE CITY
TO SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND TWO
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HE'S DIRECTORS ARE
CHOSEN BY THE CITY GROUPS TO
SERVE ON THE CHECK FOR. THIS
RESPECT BOTH THE POPULATION
BASE AS WELL AS THE MARKET
REGIONAL DIFFERENCES WITHIN THE
COUNTY. BOARD OF COMMUNITY SELF
IMPROVEMENT. CURRENTLY WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING A SERIES OF
LOCALLY GENERATED IMPROVEMENTS
OR PROCESS. I SERVED ALONGSIDE
MY COLLEAGUE VICE MAYOR JONES
AS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE AD HOC
COMMITTEE TO ENHANCE THE TEAM
GOVERNMENT. WAS ESTABLISHED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN ONE DIVERT SO
MUCH ABOUT. IN CONTRAST WAS
LEGISLATION THIS WAS AN OPEN
TRANSPARENT. I THREE GROUPS
OUTSIDE CONSULTANTS AND THE
PUBLIC. THIS IS UNLIKE THE
LEGISLATION REPORTING WHICH IS
PROPOSING A SOLUTION RESPOND
REPRESENTATIVE. L. TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT REGIONAL DIFFERENCES IN
THE COUNTY I WOULD BE IMPOSED
FROM THE STATE. IT ALSO MAKES
THE ASSUMPTION THAT LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE INCAPABLE
OF SERVING AS DIRECTORS.
INDEPENDENT DISTRICTS THIS IS
AT ODDS WITH THE MAJORITY OF
TRANSPORTATION FIFTIES
THROUGHOUT THE NATION. THE
CHASERS PORTENT PUBLIC PROPS
PURPOSE OF PROVIDING
TRANSPORTATION TO THE TRANSIT
DEPENDENT THE COMMUNITIES OF
CONCERN. IT ALSO PROVIDES MAJOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS AS WELL
AS ROADWAY IMPROVEMENTS AND
BIKE SICKLE A PEDESTRIAN
PROJECTS. WE GAIN VALUABLE
INSIGHT FROM ADVISORY
COMMITTEES FROM THE COMMUNITY
TRANSPORTATION PROFESSIONALS
AND LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE
GT FOUR HAS BEEN COMPRISED A
MIX OF ELECTED COUNTY AND CITY
REPRESENTS AND ALL VALUATIONS
OF THE BOARD STRUCTURE
INCLUDING MOST RECENTLY
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION.
DETERMINATIVE COURT CURRENT
BOARD COMPOSITION. IS A VERY
WORKABLE MODEL. GEN COUNTY IS
FIRST HEALTHCARE CALIFORNIA WE
PROVIDE ROBUST LOCAL SALES TAX
REVENUE TO SUPPORT A TRANSIT
SYSTEM THAT WOULD BE OTHERWISE
UNAFFORDABLE OVER THIS LARGELY
SUBURBAN BAR. DGA UNDER THE
CURRENT BOARD STRUCTURE A LONG
HISTORY OF PASSING TECH SALES
TAX MEASURES TO DELIVER
TRANSMITTED TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS WE'RE CURRENTLY
ENTERING THE SECOND PHASE OF
THE BART EXTENSION INTO SILICON
VALLEY. I DON'T NEED TO REMIND
ANYONE HERE THE PASSING THE
SALES TAX MEASURES TAKES A TO
THIRDS MAJORITY. TO SHOWS A
HIGH LEVEL PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN
PGA. ACTUALLY ASK THIS BILL NOT
BEFORE. HE CAN'T. TO IMPLEMENT
IMPROVE HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED
LOCALLY IN DIALOGUE WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY THE POTENTIAL
CHANGES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR HENDRICKS WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW HOW HOW THE VICE
MAYOR JONES. THANK YOU ARE
CHEER AGUILAR CURRY AND PRICED
YOU'RE LACKING IN THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY. AND
FIGHT MAYOR AND A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CDSL DAY.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB CA NINETY
ONE FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS.
THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
SIGNIFICANTLY ALTER THE
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE OF SANTA
CLARA VALLEY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY WITHOUT APPROPRIATE
STAKEHOLDER AND COMMUNITY INPUT.
THE CITY OF SALE THEY HAVE BY
FAR THE LARGEST YEAR NEARLY 70%
OF THE ETA TRANSIT RIDERS THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. YOUR
PERCENT OF THE COUNTY'S
RESIDENTS IN 57% OF THE
CONGESTION MANAGEMENT
INTERSECTIONS IN THE COUNTY.
HUNDRED EIGHTY TO NINETY ONE
THE CITY OF BELGRADE WOULD BE
GUARANTEED ONLY TWO OUT OF NINE
SEATS ON THE BOARD SHE CAN'T
LEAD TO LESSEN THE TICKET
CURRENT PROPORTIONAL AND
EQUITABLE REPRESENTATION OF OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND
RESIDENTS OF COLOR. EIGHTY TO
NINETY ONE X. IT THE LIKE
OFFICIAL WHO SERVED ON THE
BOARD. HE CALLED FOR A. BOARD
EXCLU ELECTED OFFICIALS
UNDERMINED AGENCY THE TO THE
PUBLIC THAT IS FUNDED. BILLION
DOLLARS A. ORGANICALLY
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE INDEPENDENT CONSULTANTS TO
IDENTIFY GOVERNANCE BEST
PRACTICES AND EVALUATE THE
CURRENT GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE.
AS A MEMBER OF THE BOARD
ENHANCE THE P. YOU CAN LOOK AT
ME SPENT HUNDREDS OF HOURS
REVIEWING NEARLY NINETY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS
THREE KEY BORGES IT IN EFFECT
YEAH. WE DIDN'T FIND A SLEW
THAT HEARING A BETTER
GOVERNANCE. IN FACT AB CA
NINETY ONE EQUITABLE
REPRESENTATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO OUR DISTRICT
CAN BE WITHOUT ANY ASSURANCES
THAT A NON ELECTED BODY BETTER
POLITICALLY. CONFEDERATION
OTHER CRITICAL GRANT YOUR
SUPPORT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE NOT. BUT THIS
AGREEMENT BUT THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE BILL
CERTAINLY DOES NOT ADDRESS THE
CORE ISSUES OF GOVERNMENT LINK
LINK TO THE GRAND JURY REPORT.
ACTUALLY WE CREATED CURRENTLY
DRAFTING THE CORE ISSUES IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
COMMUNITY IT SERVES YEAH BAKER
THE COLDEST. HERE'S WHAT THE
REASON. YOU VERY OPPOSED THIS
AB CAN ONE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS MAYOR HOW DO
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE OPERATOR.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
A. B. TEN NINETY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND I
SHOW A COMMENT COMING THROUGH
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH OUR LINE
NUMBER. WINO ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN
YEAR MIKE IS UP. THANK YOU CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU JUST YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU. PREVENT YEAH- I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT GETTING IT
EARLIER MY NAME IS RAJ THANKS
FORMER MAYOR OF CUPERTINO I
SUPPORT. CAN NINETY ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND LINE.
SEVENTY TWO. HI MY NAME IS
DARCY CALLED I AM THE CURRENT
MARITAL CUPERTINO AND ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF CUPERTINO AND
IT'S UNANIMOUS COUNCIL WE
OPPOSE AB TEN NINETY ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. AND
MADAM CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH.
WELCOME. YES THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD A
COUPLE YEARS AGO SAN DIEGO HAD
SOME SIMILAR CHALLENGES WITH
OUR ON COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS
AND MTS DOWN THE SOUTH- SO I DO
FIND THAT JACK GRAND JURY
INQUIRY IS VERY CONCERNING AND
I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT
THERE IS SOME CHANGE I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT- AB
EIGHT OH FIVE FROM ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WHEN THEY GONZALEZ- THAT
IS ACTUALLY WORKED OUT REALLY
WELL IT DOES NOT ALLOW
APPOINTMENTS AND THE YOU KNOW
WE HAD A LONG DISCUSSION ABOUT
MAYBE WE DON'T AGREE ABOUT
APPOINTMENTS- I'M PREPARED TO
LET YOU KEEP WORKING ON THIS
BILL WE HAD EXTENSIVE.
CONVERSATIONS HAPPEN TO DO
ANYTHING I CAN TO HELP OF WITH
OTHER AGENCIES HAVE STRUGGLED-
AND I DO THINK WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE- CLEAR
GUARDRAILS ON APPOINTMENTS I
THINK APPOINTMENTS THAT WE HAVE
AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMPONENT- ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION COMPONENT- ARE
ARE BETTER THAN JUST ALLOWING
RANDOM APPOINTMENTS BY PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT ELECTED I THINK
THERE IS A VALUE IN HAVING
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES ON
REGIONAL BOARDS AND I
UNDERSTAND CURRENTLY IN YOUR
DISTRICT IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN
MINE- PEOPLE NEED TO HAVE FULL
TIME JOBS AS WELL AND SO
SOMETIMES THERE MIGHT BE A
PROBLEM. WITH DOING THAT SO I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT TO SPONSOR YOU
TOO MUCH TO KEEP WORKING ON IT
AND THEN WE CAN WE CONSIDER.
WHEN IT COMES THE FOR. IF YOU
OR SOMEONE BROWN AND IT'S THE
PRIOR CONVERSE. IN THIS. FOR TO
LOOK AT AND RENTING I'M GONNA
TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT THAT AND-
YOU KNOW IT. I'LL STOP THERE
AND ALL THE OTHER QUESTIONS AND
CLOSE BRIDGET THANKS. FOR THEIR
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LUCKY. YEAH WE
IN THE SPOKEN PREVIOUSLY I'VE-
SERVED ON CUBA TRANSPORTATION
BOARDS BOTH WITH THE- APPOINTED
AND ELECTED AND I THINK THE
HYBRID MODEL. BECAUSE I THINK
BOTH HAVE MERIT IF DONE
PROPERLY- I THINK THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE FOR
ELECTED OFFICIALS IS IMPORTANT.
AND I THINK THAT APPOINTED
MEMBERS SOMETIMES HAVE
EXPERTISE. AND THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE. GREATER INSIGHT. BUT
TO HAVE JUST ALL OF ONE. I
THINK IS A- VERY DIFFICULT HAVE
GOOD GOVERNANCE AND WHAT THE
TRANSPORTATION BOARDS I SERVED
ON HAVE HIGHBRIDGE. AND I THINK
THAT THEY HAVE SERVED THE
PUBLIC WELL AND SO. I'M NOT
PREPARED TO SUPPORT IT AT THIS
POINT BUT ALL SUPPORT ON THE
FLOOR IF YOU'RE ABLE TO GET
THERE THANK YOU. DID MITCHELL I
AM GLAD I HELD OFF ON MY
COMMENTS TO MS BROWN FORGOT
BECAUSE IT IS ALWAYS A WE ARE
LOOKING AT AS A HYBRID IDEA-
AND THEN MAYBE. YOU KNOW HAVING
BOTH ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
APPOINTED OFFICIALS THERE ARE A
LOT OFTRANSIT AGENCIES OUT
THERE THAT JUST OF ELECTED
THERE ARE. SOME VERY GOOD
TRANSIT AGENCIES OTHER THAT
JUST HAVE APPOINTED- AND I GOT
A LIST OF THOSE THAT ALSO VERY
ALL RIGHT NOW BUT BUT I DO
THINK THAT A HYBRID MAYBE YOU
CAN. HAVE YOUR CAKE AND EAT IT
TOO- SO I APPRECIATE THAT
COMMENTED SOMETHING WE'RE GOING
TO LOOK A LOT MORE AT. IF THE
BILL GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS YES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RESERVE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I JUST WANT TO-
THANK. THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
YEAH I REPRESENT THE SOUTH
VALLEY THAT- IN THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA. AND SO CERTAINLY
THERE- ARE CONCERNS THAT ARE
THERE BUT I. YOU KNOW REALLY
APPRECIATE LEVEL ENGAGEMENT YOU
HAVE WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
MYSELF IN PARTICULAR REACHED
OUT YOU KNOW. MONTHS AGO- AND I
TRUST THAT YOU COULD CONTINUE
TO DO THE WORK- AND- I APPLAUD
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO- YOU
KNOW AS- OUR COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED- YOU KNOW THE CITED.
ISSUES BY. THREE DIFFERENT
GRAND JURIES IS A PROBLEM. AND
SO WOULD HOPE THAT- THIS
DISCUSSION CONTINUE- AND THAT
WE WORK TO. RESOLVE THESE LONG
STANDING ISSUES AND- THESE
CONCERNS THAT EXIST- AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO REALLY BECAUSE
YOU DO ONE AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
BRIGIDA MYSTERY OF US AND THEN
OF ENJOY THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE
HAD WITH THE MAYORS OF MORGAN
HILL AND GILROY AND I PROMISED
THEM THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT SOUTH COUNTIES
CONCERNS ARE ARE ADDRESSED AND-
WE SHOULD HAVE IN THE SERVICES
SUPPORT SHOULD ALSO. WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE WHO IS ALSO ONE OF THE FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO REPRESENTS
IN A CAR COUNTY. HAS ASKED TO
JOIN AS A CO AUTHOR F THE BILL
ON SO WE'RE DOING WHAT WE CAN
TO- YEAH I HAVE THE
CONVERSATIONS NECESSARY IN
ADDRESS PEOPLE'S CONCERNS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT SAYING THEN WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SOME MEMBER ALMOST IN
A SECOND BOMB ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS HOW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD
BEFORE THE HEARING IN THE
SUGGESTIONS OF THAT. FOLKS HAVE
HAVE PROVIDED ME- AND DAN A LOT
OF THE COMING FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH IF THE
BILL GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANKS WELL THANK YOU SOME
REMEMBER AND I KNOW THESE LOCAL
ISSUES ARE ALWAYS DIFFICULT-
THOUGH IT'S HARD TO SOMETIMES
FACE UR CONSTITUENTS BUT WE
GOTTA DO THE RIGHT THING. I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OF
THE OPPOSITION AS WELL AS THE
THOSE THAT SUPPORT THE BILL SO
WE CAN GET TO A GOOD PLACE FOR
YOU SO TODAY I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL AND THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
ALL RIGHT MACKEY NOT KNOWING
EXACTLY THAT. VOTING BLOW- I.
BURNER BOERNER HORVATH I'M-
RAMOS HI LOS RIVAS. THREE OF US
I ROB. ROBERT RIVAS OKAY. HI
VOEPEL HI YOU HAVE A SET SEAT.
OKAY THAT. NOT HOLD IT OPEN I
THINK EVER. ALWAYS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. WELCOME
IS MEMBER CAREER THIS IS NO.
THREE EIGHT SIX THIRTY FOUR.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WHAT A PRIVILEGE I
THINK THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT I'M ACTUALLY PRESENTING IN
YOUR COMMITTEE SO GOOD TO BE
HERE I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
SIX THREE FOR A MEASURE THAT
WILL HELP ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
EXTEND THE AFFORDABILITY TERM
FOR FUTURE HOUSING UNITS THAT
QUALIFY A DEVELOPER FOR A
DENSITY BONUS BEYOND FIFTY FIVE
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA THE DENSITY
BONUS LAW WAS CREATED AS A TOOL
TO HELP ADDRESS A SHORTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BY
INCLUDING AFFORDABLE UNITS IN
THE DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPER
CIRCUIT GRANTED AN INCREASE IN
DENSITY OVER CITY SUNTAN CITY
THIS INCREASE IN DENSITY
CONCESSIONS AND INCENTIVES ARE
AIMED TO FINANCIALLY SUPPORT
THE INCLUSION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CURRENTLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE REQUIRED TO
ADOPT INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
ORDINANCE THAT REQUIRED
DEVELOPER TO INCLUDE A
PERCENTAGE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON SITE OR PAY IN LIEU
FEE TO FUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ELSEWHERE IN THE COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER UNDER THE CURRENT LAW
FOR DEVELOPERS SUBJECT TO
INCLUSIONARY SET ASIDE
REQUIREMENTS AND DEVELOPER
ELECTS TO UTILIZE A DENSITY
BONUS PROGRAM THEN THE
AFFORDABILITY DURATION OF A
RENTAL SET ASIDE UNITS UNDER
BOTH PROGRAMS WOULD BE FIFTY
FIVE YEARS IN SOME CASES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING ORDINANCES REQUIRE
LONGER AFFORDABILITY COVENANTS
THAN FIFTY FIVE YEARS FOR
EXAMPLE LAST YEAR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FINALIZE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF ITS INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
ORDINANCE WHICH REQUIRED THE
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING SET ASIDES
AND RENTAL HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
TO BE AFFORDABLE. IN PERPETUITY.
AB SIXTY FOUR CLARIFIES THAT
FOR THE UNITS IN A DEVELOPMENT
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY
WITH THE INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
ORDINANCE. THE COVENANT CAN BE
LONGER THAN FIFTY FIVE YEARS IF
THE INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
ORDINANCE REQUIRES A LONGER
PERIOD. AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY ON
THE LINE IS AMY VOTED WITH THE
L. A. DEPARTMENT OF REGIONAL
PLANNING. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
OUR LOOKING FOR AMY BURDICK.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK THIS AFTERNOON AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO THANK
YOU INTRODUCTION MY NAME IS AMY
ABOUT ACT. I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
REGIONAL PLANNING FOR THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND I AM
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS H. AS THOSE
MENTIONED AB SIX THREE FOUR
WOULD ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SUCH AS THE COUNTY TO EXTEND BE
AFFORDABILITY TERMS. FOR FUTURE
HOUSING UNITS CREATED UNDER
STATE AND LOCAL HOUSING
PROGRAMS FOR LONGER THAN FIFTY
FIVE YEARS BASED ON A LOCAL
ORDINANCE. WE ALL KNOW THAT
THERE IS A HOUSING CRISIS
ACROSS THE STATE WHICH IS NO
LESS ACUTE IN L. A. COUNTY.
OVER THE PAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS
L. A. COUNTY HAS TAKEN DRAMATIC
STEPS TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS IN
THE COUNTY'S UNINCORPORATED
AREAS. THEY HAVE ADOPTED TWO
LANDMARK POLICIES INCLUDING AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRESERVATION
ORDINANCE. EIGHT FIVE RIGHT
HOUSING ORDINANCE. AN INTERIM
AND SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
ORDINANCE A VERY PROGRESSIVE
DENSITY BONUS ORDINANCE THAT
GOES BEYOND STATE DENSITY BONUS
REQUIREMENTS. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE MANDATORY
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING ORDINANCE
WHICH HOWEVER WHEN WE COMBINE
THE INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
ORDINANCE WITH THE DENSITY
BONUS ORDINANCE. THAT
AFFORDABILITY DURATION MUST BE
FIFTY FIVE YEARS WHICH IS THE
LIMITS UNDER THE STATE DENSITY
BONUS LAW. THIS BILL AB SIX
THREE FOUR. BUT PROVIDE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO VOLUNTARILY EXTENDS THOSE
COVENANTS BEYOND SIXTY FIVE
YEARS PROVIDING A CRITICAL TOOL
TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. THIS
BILL DOES NOT AFFECT THEIR
JURISDICTIONS SINGLE FAMILY
ZONING NOR DOES IT CREATE A
FINANCIAL BURDEN TO ANY OF THE
MUNICIPALITY. ALLOWING A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO EXPAND THAT
AFFORDABILITY TERM FOR FUTURE
UNITS FOR LONGER THAN FIFTY
FIVE YEARS RESULTS IN A LONGER
TERM AFFORDABILITY ON NEW
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. AND ENSURE
THAT HUMANITIES ARE ABLE TO
PRESERVE THEIR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STOCK FOR THE LONG
TERM. IT IS REALLY A SIMPLE
CHECKS BUT ONE THAT WE THINK
WOULD HAVE FAR REACHING
POSITIVE BENEFITS IN
STABILIZING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AVAILABILITY. IN SHORT WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WELL- AGAIN VERY
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS TOPIC AND I YIELD. TO THE
REMAINDER OF MY TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DO WE HVE
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. IN THE GALLERY SEEING
NONE OPERATOR- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE. FOUR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THE ROLE
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE NINE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR I DON'T HAVE
ANYONE REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION
BUT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION IN
HERE IN THE GALLERY. SEEING
NONE ARE THERE ANY OPPOSITION
ON THE- PHONE AGAIN WITH AB.
SIX THIRTY FOUR. OUR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO A B. X. THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
TEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE ONE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE HOLD WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
FOR. THANK YOU. ALAINA ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
SUSAN KIRSCH CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CATALYST. AND WE ARE OPPOSED
TO SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY FOUR
AND A MULTITUDE OF DENSITY
BONUSES THAT ARE BENEFITING
DEVELOPERS BUT HAVE A CHANCE TO
BANKRUPT CITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER. WITNESSES
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THE TIME OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ABOUT QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. WE HAVE A
MOTION ENVIRONMENT. SO I JUST
WANNA CONFIRM THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS BILL IS
ONE CITIES HAVE TO CHOOSE TO
OPT IN RIGHT SO THE NUMBER NOT
MANDATING ANYTHING FOR THE
STATE CITIES CHOOSE TO OPT IN
IT DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING THE
UNDERLYING PRINCIPLES LAW THE
ONLY CHANGES ALLOWING CITIES TO
GO AFTER- GO TO ALLOWING CITIES
TO CHOOSE TO GO BEYOND FIFTY
FIVE YEARS AFFORDABILITY. THAT
IS CORRECT YES I WAS NOT THE
FIFTY FIVE YEARS AFFORDABILITY
WAS THAT WHEN I WAS ON THE
INTERNET CITY COUNCIL WAS SUCH
A WEIRD NUMBER SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS COMING THROUGH
YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE I WAS
I WAS TALKING WHEN I WAS
READING THE BILL. YOU KNOW THIS
ISN'T A BILL FOR REALLY US THIS
IS A BILL FOR MY DAUGHTER'S
CHILDREN SO ON THE BEHALF OF MY
DAUGHTER'S FUTURE CHILDREN
THANK YOU FOR. KEEPING HOUSING
AFFORDABLE IN CALIFORNIA. I
THINK. IS THERE ANY OTHER
COMMITMENT COMMITTEE COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FACING NON ON
ENTERTAIN A MOTION WE HAVE A
FIRST BUT WE HAVE A FIRST BY
SOME MEMBER RAMOS SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US I
WOULD YOU LIKE TO KEEP A CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'LL JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING IS A TREMENDOUS TO THE
WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIANS IN
NEED- AB SIXTY FOUR IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO ADD TO ADD TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TOOLBOX
TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES- TACKLE MY
COLLEAGUE- OF MS BURNETTE ****
BATH WE ARE EXPERIENCING MY
COMMUNITY AND MY DISTRICT OF
CHINATOWN- THESE COVENANTS THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE LASTED FOR A NEXT
MAN OF YEARS THT HAVE EXPIRED
AND NOW THE CHILDREN OF PARENTS
WHO HAVE BEEN LIVING IN IN
THESE UNITS FOR QUITE SOME TIME
ARE EXPERIENCING A VERY SEVERE
A SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AS WELL AS BEING
DISPLACED IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
SO I REALLY DO HOPE THAT
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT A MANDATE
THIS IS AN OPT IN. THAT LOCAL
CITIES DO THE RIGHT THING AND
ACTUALLY EXPAND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO THAT WE'RE NOT IN
THE SITUATION CONTINUED CYCLE
OF EVICTIONS AND INABILITY TO
ACTUALLY FIND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD I COULDN'T AGREE WITH
YOU MORE AND I MUST AGREE WITH
US ON MEMBER BERNHARDT PARVATHY
HELLO MY GOD WE WILL BE HERE
BUT OUR KIDS WILL BE HIT WITH
THE TABLE WITH THIS- I THINK
THE BILL'S GOING TO HELP ENSURE
LONG TERM PRESERVATION OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS I'M PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
HAI LACKEY LACKEY. NARROW BLOOM.
BLOOM I BURN A- BOERNER HORVATH
I. RAMOS RAMOS HI LOU. THIS
WITH I ROBERT REED. VOEPEL WILL
TELL DEL IS. FIVE TWO. FIVE BOB
HOPE PHONE BILLS. THANK YOU.
COME BACK AGAIN SOMETIME. OKAY
NICK WE HAVE I DON'T KNOW FOUR
AND THIS IS A TWENTY FOUR SOME
MEMBER FOR. WELL TO PROCEED
WHEN YOU READY OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND ON A PERSONAL
THANK YOU AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL ALL OF YOUR HELP MUCH
APPRECIATED AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR IS A REALLY A CONSUMER
PROTECTION MEASURE THAT JUST
INSURES THAT CITIES
MUNICIPALITIES DON'T PRICE
GOUGE CONSUMERS WHO WANT TO PUT
SOLAR ON THEIR HOMES I DID A
BILL A FEW YEARS AGO AB
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN THAT HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THAT DID
THIS FOR RESIDENTIAL SOLAR AND
IT'S BEEN WORKING OUT JUST FINE
DOES IT IS A GONE BANKRUPT
TRYING TO PERMIT TO OUR
PEOPLE'S ROOFTOP SOLAR BUT WHAT
HAS BEEN HAPPENING IS THAT SOME
CITIES HAVE BEEN CHARGING
REALLY EXORBITANT FEES TO
PERMIT OTHER THINGS THAT WERE
MADE ON SPECIFICALLY UNDER THAT
ORIGINAL BILL LIKE- SO THE
PEOPLE PUT ON CARPORTS- THAT
KIND OF THING SHADE STRUCTURES
A ONE CASE A SCHOOL WANTED TO
PUT OR OR SOME BECAUSE SOME
PLACE WANTED TO PUT ONE OF
THESE BIG SOLAR CARPORTS OVER
THE PARKING LOT. AND THE CITY
AND THE CITY CAME OUT AND
WANTED LIKE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS TO PERMIT IT EVEN
THOUGH REALLY THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THAT FIRST BILL OF
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN WAS TO
STREAMLINE THE PERMITTING OF
THIS AND MAKING IT REASONABLE
FOR PEOPLE SO THIS BILL JUST
ALLOWS FOR THOSE TYPES OF
STRUCTURES TO ALSO BE
PERMITTED- OF FOUR OR MORE MUCH
MORE REASONABLE COST AND WITH
MORE. PREDICTABILITY FOR THOSE
WHO WANT TO PUT THESE UP SO
ALLOW CITIES TO DO SAFETY
INSPECTIONS AND SO ALLOWS FOR
THEM TO EVEN ARGUE THAT
SOMETHING'S MORE COMPLICATED
AND SHOULD HAVE HAVE A HIGHER
FEE STRUCTURE THEY CAN DO THAT
IF THEY MAKE FINDINGS AND
REALLY YOU KNOW ADULT THOSE
FINDINGS- SO. WITH THAT I WOULD
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL MOVE INTO WE- IN
SUPPORT AND LOOK FOR WE HAVE A
MISSED BINGE. DAVIS WE'RE
LOOKING FOR SUPPORT. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I AM I HEARD YES
YOU ARE. GREAT THANK YOU MY
NAME IS BENJAMIN DAVIS I AM AN
ASSOCIATE WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION
WE REPRESENT MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED SOLAR COMPANIES THAT
CONDUCT BUSINESS IN THE STATE
WE ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO CHECK
OUT THE BILL. THE MOST BUILDING
DEPARTMENTS COMPLY WITH THE
LETTER AND INTENT OF PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION THAT AB FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN WHICH THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CREDENTIALS BY OUT. I'M
TED CAPS ON THE FEES BUILDING
DEPARTMENTS CAN CHARGE TO ISSUE
PERMITS TO INSTALL SOLAR.
ADDRESS PREVIOUS LEGISLATION
HAVE A LOT FOR MORE HOMES AND
BUSINESSES TO GO SOLAR. NOT
ONLY BY KEEPING THE COSTS LOW
THE MARKET. HOWEVER THERE ARE A
FEW BUILDING DEPARTMENT THAT
EXPLOIT LOOPHOLES IN THE
EXISTING CAPS ON THE FEES.
ARCMINUTES WELL BREAK THE FEES
IN TWO PIECES SO THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL PIECES ARE BELOW THE
CAPS BUT THE SOME OF THE PIECES
A CREEPY CAPS. THE BUILDING
DEPARTMENTS CAN ALSO CLAIM THAT
THE PURPOSE OF A SOLAR SYSTEM
IS SOMETHING OTHER THAN
GENERATING SOLAR ENERGY AND
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO EXCEED THE
CAPS AS WELL. TO REITERATE MOST
BUILDING DEPARTMENT FOLLOW THE
CAPS- FOR ALL TYPES OF SYSTEMS
BUT FOR THE ONES THAT DO NOT.
YEAH IT CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT
TO INSTALL SOLAR THERE.
SOMETIMES D. EXTRA FEES ARE A
FEW HUNDRED DOLLARS MORE I
WHICH IS THE COST THE COST OF
MORE- THE SOLAR COMPANY IS
WILLING TO PAY. OTHER TIMES SO
THE COSTS OF THE PERMIT CAN BE
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS INSTEAD OF
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS. I AND I
CAN REALLY JEOPARDIZE THE
ENTIRE PROJECT. SO WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR BECAUSE IT WOULD PREVENT
BUILDING DEPARTMENT TARGET
SPORTING PEOPLE POLLS. AND MORE
HOMES AND BUSINESSES I WOULD BE
ABLE TO INSTALL SOLAR- CAL. HAS
HALF OF ALL SOLAR INSTALLATIONS
IN THE COUNTRY AND THAT IS NOT
A COINCIDENCE I WE HAVE A LOT
OF SUN OF COURSE BUT WE ALSO
HVE A HISTORY OF PATENT
POLICIES. THAT REMOVE BARRIERS
STAND IN THE WAY OF MARCH
CALIFORNIANS GOING TELLER. I AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR WOULD
CONTINUE TO REMOVE SUCH
BARRIERS. ALLOWING FOR THE
GRANT OF SELLER ACROSS THE
STATE. THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER DAVIS DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY. WELCOME VENTURE
MEMBERS BILL MCGOVERN WITH
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE TELEPHONE LINE
OPERATOR. FOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
LINE ONE HUNDRED TWELVE YEAR
MIKE IS UP. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STILL THE-
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF SUNPOWER
CORPORATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I NAY. EIGHTY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA AND SPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I AM NOT. ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN. JULIN
MALINOWSKI BALL ON THE HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND
LODGING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT. WELL IN
MY WITH THE CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
CALLING THE BY. THANK YOU. FIND
THAT. ONE HUNDRED TWENTY SIX.
OKAY HELLO YES WE CAN WE CAN
HEAR. I GOT HOME OWNERSHIP
POWER AND AN EMAIL AND WE
INSTALL SOLAR SHADE STRUCTURES
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON TO
RAINY HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE
SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION INSTRUCT THE PORT.
THANK YOU. FINE ONE HUNDRED
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MARGARET MILLER WITH ANGIE
NORTH AMERICA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I'M NOT
LINE SEVENTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON IT'S ABOUT THAT SAYS
LET'S GO SOMEWHERE INTERNET
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA CALLING
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
AND W HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE ANY WTNESSES
OPPOSITION I DO HAVE A- A TRACY
RYAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ON THE
PHONE. TRACY YOU CAN BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRACY RYAN ON BEHALF OF
THE WORLD COUNTY AT THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
URBAN COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR WE
UNDERSTAND THE ACTOR STATED
INTENT IN BRINGING ELEVEN
TWENTY FALL FORWARD AND AGREE
WE SHOULD TAKE STEPS TO ENSURE
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
NOT ACTING IN BAD FAITH WHEN
CONSIDERING SMALL SCALE SOLAR
PROJECTS SUCH AS SOLAR CARPORT.
I MEAN CONSUMER STRUCTURES. AND
WE SUPPORT THAT HELP APPLE ST
NEW TOWARD MEETING OUR GREEN.
GAS WOULD GOALS MORE
IMPORTANTLY RESIDENTS IN LOW
THE CALIFORNIA THAT ARE NOW
ENTERING YES YES AND WHAT PER
SEASON WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
FAMILY MEMBER FRIEDMAN GOAL TO
BUILD A MORE RELIABLE ELECTRIC
GRAND. HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED MAKE IT FURTHER THAN
SIMPLY CLARIFYING THAT FULLER
CAN ACHIEVE SO MUCH SHADE
STRUCTURES NO AND LIKE PROJECTS
ARE SUBJECT TO. IN INTERPOL
PERMITTING PROCESS. DANTE CAPS.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR EXPAND
DEATH OF SOLAR ENERGY TO
INCLUDE THOSE SPECIAL DEVICE
EACH. THAT ARE NOT MOUNTED A
BUILDING STYLE PLACE ON THE
GROUND. IN THE INTEREST PAID
PUBLISHED. WITHOUT ANY. ON
FIVE. BY A MINISTERIAL. TO
POSSIBLY YOU CHAU ME SOLAR
PROJECT AB ELEVEN TWENTY WOULD
REMOVE. THROUGH THE BODY WEIGHT
BY IMPACT. ALL PLEDGING NAMES
BECAUSE ON. ADDITIONALLY THIS
EXPANDED. QUITE THE CAPTAIN
CURRENT LAW CREATING CONCERN
FOR BUILDING OFFICIALS ON THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF SUCH. ONE
RECOGNIZES THAT THERE IN IMPACT
AND COMPLEX OF ROOFTOPS ENERGY
SYSTEMS IN THOSE SYSTEMS. TO
STRETCH. OR SCALE. AGAIN I CAN
IS THE AMBIGUITY OF THE
EXPANSION BEYOND RESIDENTIAL
SOLAR IN THE UNKNOWN IMPACTS TO
THE ENVIRONMENT IN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
ESTELAR. BOB IF LARGE SOLAR
FARM TECH PROJECTS OR STUDY TO
ONLY A MINISTER THAT USED BY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE DOCTORS OFFICE TO SEE IF
THEY CAN FIND A WAY TO CLARIFY
THE EXTENT BUT- AT ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS RAIMES LET'S
MOVE ON TO OTHER WITNESSES. IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR. FOR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE TEN ZERO. WE HAVE A
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE NUMBER. AN
OUTLINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTEEN
YEAR MIKE IS UP. THANK YOU
BRADY COULD NOT BE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS
ARE ONE OF HER COMMANDS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN'S
OFFICE FOR A SITTING DOWN WITH
US EARLIER TODAY TO FIND COMMON
GROUND ON THIS BILL BUT WE ARE
STILL RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO MORE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY QUESTION I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY AS WELL. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING
THIS FORWARD- ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE SOLAR AND ALL FORMS AND
THEN IT'S EASY. TO PERMIT IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND ARE HAPPY
TO SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SAYING NONE- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH AND A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LUCKY- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YES- FIRST I WANT TO- JUST OF
THE STATE THAT WE ARE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TALKING WITH.
THESE ARE AGENCIES THAT HAVE
SOME CONCERNS THE BILL DOES NOT
DOES NOT REMOVE ANYBODY'S
ABILITY TO PERMIT AND TO HAVE
AN ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS. THIS IS NOT CHANGE THE
RIGOR OF THE PERMIT THAT A CITY
WOULD GO THROUGH THE SIMPLY
FOCUSES ON THE FEES THAT ARE
CHARGED. THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS
FOR THE FEE SCALE TO INCREASE
THE SIZE OF THE PROJECT
INCREASES SO WE'RE TRYING TO BE
VERY MINDFUL TO MAKE SURE IT'S
WORKABLE. BUT WE SIMPLY CANNOT
ALLOW PRESS PRICE GOUGING WHEN
IT COMES TO SOLAR WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY IF YOU AGENCIES
ARE DOING. BUT THIS DOES NOT
MAKE THE PERMITTING MINISTERIAL
IT STILL ALLOWS FOR SAFETY
INSPECTIONS TO BE DONE TO MAKE
SURE STRUCTURES ARE SAFE. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN CLARIFY THAT IF THAT'S
STILL NOT WELL UNDERSTOOD BY
THE COUNTIES. WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO MEMBER BRING IT
FORWARD TO CLARIFY THE PERMIT
FEES THAT LOCAL AGENCIES MAY
IMPOSE ON SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS.
AND I APPRECIATE WILL AND
WILLINGNESS TO CONSIDER THE
BROADER APPLICATION THE CHANGES
TO THE DEFINITION OF SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEMS. HAVE AMPLE IN
OTHER AREAS OF LAW I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS THOSE POTENTIAL
IMPACTS ALSO BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AND WE ARE CLOSED HI
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
IDALOU. HELLO I BURDEN. I RAMOS
WELL THE I MOVED. THREE OF US I
WOULD REED. OKAY VOEPEL I SEVEN
ZERO OKAY THAT'S GOING WALK
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ADD
ONS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBERS- AB A
EIGHTY- SOMEONE MATH. AND THE
WELCOME PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY-
IN THAT CASE ALL I KEEP IT
SHORTS MEMBERS AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
ADDS FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBES TO OUR
CURRENT LIST OF LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE A RIGHT OF FIRST
REFUSAL WHEN PURCHASING SURPLUS
LANDS I ASK YOU FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WITH ME TOO J. TO TESTIFY. IS
CARRIE PATTERSON WHO IS THE
ATTORNEY FOR THE TULE RIVER
TRIBE AND CHAIRMAN WILLIAM
GARFIELD OF THE TULE RIVER
TRIBE WHO CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE- MISS
PATTERSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM HERE- AS OUTSIDE
LEGAL COUNSEL FOR THE TRIBE IN
THE SAMPLE TO ANSWER ANY. LEGAL
OR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE BUT I'M GOING TO ALLOW
CHAIRMAN GARFIELD TO PROVIDE-
ARE- STATEMENT TODAY CHAIRMAN
GARFIELD. WELCOME CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- DIRECTOR
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS WAYNE
BURKE I AM THE CHAIRMAN OF
BETWEEN THE RIVER TRIED- LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRY COMES TODAY.
IN SUPPORT OF MENDING A. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY. UNFORTUNATELY AS
WRITTEN THE CALIFORNIA SURPLUS
LAND ACT EXCLUDES FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES. WORKING WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PURCHASE
SURPLUS LANDS. THE TO READ THIS
PURPOSE SPONSOR THIS BILL
BECAUSE- THIS LEADS THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD AMEND THE ACT
AND PROVIDE ALL FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY THAT LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES HAVE
WHEN PURCHASING SURPLUS LANDS.
SADLY THE PEOPLE TO THE RIVER
LIKE OTHER CALIFORNIA TRIBES.
QUESTION THEIR HOMELANDS
DETECTING CORRUPTION DURING
THOSE TIMES MANY OF OUR PEOPLE
TO EVEN SPEAK ENGLISH AND DO
POWER PRESENTATION HAD SENT
OVER MUCH OF THOSE LANDS. MORE
OPEN IF THIS LEGISLATION PASSES
THE PEOPLE TO THE RIVER. AND
OTHER CALIFORNIA TRIBES CAN
WORK WITH THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CONTINUE TO
REVITALIZE EACH OTHER'S
COMMUNITIES STRENGTHEN
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS PROVIDE
HOUSING SOON ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. FOR THE FUTURE OF
THEIR CITIZENS THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE. A SOLUTION FOR THAT ARE
THE RECOGNIZED TRIBES TO
PURCHASE SURPLUS LANDS THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH THE SAME
RESPECT GIVEN TO ALL OTHER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. CURRENTLY
OUR TRIBE WORKS CLOSELY WITH
THE STUDENT PORTAL ON SHARED
PLANNING PROJECTS LIKE WATER
TREATMENT AND FIRE PREVENTION.
AND TO THE BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY DOES NOT HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION MANY OF THE
TRIBES OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA OREGON.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THIS BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN- DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THERE NONE IN THE GO.
ON THE PHONE. YOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. WE
HAVE A COMMENT COMING THROUGH
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. IN LINE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT- MY COULD OPEN.
CRITICALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
AT THIS TIME GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HI HAVE NONE LISTED.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY
SAYING NONE. OUR POSITION ON
THE PHONE. OR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
I COMMANDED IN. ONE ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
OPERATOR WILL MOVE ON TO ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AND WE HAVE A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALMOST. WOULD YOU LIKE TO-
CLOSE- MADAM CHAIR- THANK YOU
THINK YOUR STAFF FOR HELPING
WITH THE BILL- MEMBERS ASK YOU
FOR AN AYE VOTE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRING IN THE BILL
FORMED. IT IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT WE CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES TO TRANSFER IN
CENTRAL. CENTRAL LAND BACK TO
THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS WHENEVER
POSSIBLE. I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
AND YOUR SPONSORS TO KEEP AN
OPEN MIND SUPPORTING
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THIS FOR
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES AS
WELL AS NON FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES. AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
HAI LACKEY. LACKEY I BLOOM.
BLOOM HI BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS. WELLS
FARGO'S RIVAS THREE OF US I
ROBERT RIVAS. ROBERT RIVAS I
VOEPEL. HI EIGHT ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT- NICK THEY YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS A GOING TO I
NUMBER. THE SINCE WE DON'T HAVE
WE WANT TO HEAR THIS WILL BE AB
EIGHT THIRTY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM. AGAIN THAT'S AN
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB. EIGHT
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF ON
AMENDMENTS AND THAT WILL BE
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS TODAY.
AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT WOULD SUNSET
MORE RESTRICTIVE LAND USE
REGULATIONS CONTAINED AND
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT PLANS AND
HELP BUILD NEEDED HOUSING.
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES OR RDAS
WERE DISSOLVED IN TWENTY TWELVE
AND SUCCESSOR AGENCIES WERE
CREATED TO WIND DOWN THEIR
ACTIVITIES. DUE TO ITS SIZE AND
SCOPE THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
DID NOT ELECT TO BECOME THE
SUCCESSOR AGENCY TO THEIR
FORMER RDA. INSTEAD GOVERNOR
BROWN APPOINTED A DESIGNATED
LOCAL AUTHORITY TO TAKE ON THE
DUTIES OF A SUCCESSOR AGENCY.
DESPITE THE DISSOLUTION LAND
USE REGULATIONS UNDER RDA
REMAIN IN EFFECT IN THE CITY.
RTA'S MORE STRINGENT LAND USE
POLICIES HAVE CONFLICTED WITH
PROGRAMS THAT WERE CREATED
UNDER VOTER APPROVED MEASURE
JJJ- NAMELY THE TRANSIT TO
ORIENTED COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
THE INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN THE
FORMER REDEVELOPMENT PLANS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INCENTIVES
HAVE LED TO ONEROUS LAWSUITS
AND DELAYS IN HOUSING
PRODUCTION AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO
WILL SIMPLY PROVIDE CLARITY BY
SUNSETTING THE MORE RESTRICTIVE
LAND USE REGULATIONS IN THE
FORMER RDA. THE BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT THE CITY CONTINUES
TO MEET ITS OBLIGATIONS UNDER
MEASURE JJJ. TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INCENTIVES.
THE UNIQUE NATURE OF LA'S
REDEVELOPMENT TO SOLUTION
REQUIRES LEGISLATION TO REMOVE
UNNECESSARY HURDLES AND BOOST
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT CLOSER TO
TRANSIT AND JOBS. AND LASTLY
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION. FIRST OF THE BILL IN
NO WAY INTENSELY WIPE AWAY
HISTORIC DISTRICT PRESERVATION
OF MY OFFICE IS WORKING WITH
HOLLYWOOD HERITAGE ON SOLUTIONS
TO THEIR CONCERNS. AND
ADDITIONALLY SOME ADVOCATES
HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERNS OVER
SECTION THREE THREE FOUR ONE
THREE OF THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE THAT IS REFERENCED IN THE
BILL. AND I'LL BE REMOVING THE
REFERENCE TO SECTION THREE
THREE FOUR ONE THREE FROM THE
BILL AND WE'LL DO THOSE
AMENDMENTS ON THE FLOOR WHERE
THE BILL IS HEADED NEXT SHOULD
BE. FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO GATHER
A MAJORITY OF US TODAY.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL OUR GREG BULLOCK PLANNING
DIRECTOR FOR THE OFFICE OF
COUNCILMEMBER MITCH O'FARRELL
THANK YOU GREAT- WELCOME MR
BOUGHT UP RAIDERS WERE LOOKING
FOR CRAIG BULLOCK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CRAIG
BALKENENDE PLANNING DIRECTOR
FOR COUNCILMEMBER MITCH
O'FARRELL. PRIOR TO JOINING
COUNTS MEMBER OF PERILS OFFICE
I WORKED FOR FIVE YEARS FOR THE
C. R. A. L. A. A DESIGNATED
LOCAL AUTHORITY AND SUCCESSOR
AGENCY TO THE FORMER COMMUNITY
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY AT THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. PRIOR TO
THAT I WORK FOR THE COMMUNITY
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY AT THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES FOR EIGHT
YEARS. MY RESPONSIBILITIES
THERE INCLUDED THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE LAND USE
AUTHORITIES OF THE REAL OF
THESE REDEVELOPMENT PLANS. I
FIRST WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLAME FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL THE
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
MULTIPLE REDEVELOPMENT PLANS
AND LOS ANGELES ARE SERIOUS AND
HAVE BEEN OBSTACLES IN CREATING
HOUSING. ESPECIALLY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THE REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES WERE DISSOLVED NEARLY
A DECADE AGO WE CONTINUE TO BE
HAMPERED BY THEIR OUTDATED
REQUIREMENTS. SUCH HINDRANCES
INCLUDE MORE RESTRICTIVE
DENSITY AND THAT THEY ARE
LIMITATIONS IN THE COMMUNITY
PLANS AND ZONING. THEY PREVENT
THE USE OF THE CITY'S TRANSIT
ORIENTED COMMUNITIES PROGRAM A
VOTER APPROVED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING INCENTIVE PROGRAM WHICH
INCLUDES GREATER DENSITY. THAN
THE STATE DENSITY PROGRAM TO
ACHIEVE ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND IT ALSO INCLUDES
THE MUCH NEEDED. EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME CATEGORY. THREE PLAN OF
ALL BEEN A SORE OF BALD LOS.
WHICH HAVE SLOWED HOUSING
PRODUCTION INCLUDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHICH IN TURN HAS
INCREASED COST OF HOUSING AND
ONE OF THE STATE'S MOST
EXPENSIVEHOUSING MARKETS. DID
BETTER EXAMPLES EXIST IN A
LITIGATION FILED AGAINST THEM
ON A CO A 100% AFFORDABLE
SENIOR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IN
HOLLYWOOD. IN ADDITION PASSED
THERE WAS HOLLYWOOD A PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROJECT WAS
ALSO LITIGATED AGAINST USING
THE HOLLYWOOD REDEVELOPMENT
PLAN AS THE BASIS OF THE
LITIGATION. THE DELAY HAS
INCREASED THE COST OF THE
POLICY THOUGH BY TWELVE
PERCENT. CLAIMS AGAINST THE
BILL IN LARGE PART ARE BEING
MADE BY INDIVIDUALS AND PARTIES
ASSOCIATED WITH PLAINTIFFS THAT
HAVE A HISTORY OF FILING
LITIGATION AGAINST THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY THE
SUCCESSOR AGENCY AND THE CITY.
IN THE LAST THREE TO FOUR YEARS
THAT LITIGATION HAS INVOLVED
THOUSANDS OF UNITS OF HOUSING.
INCLUDING HUNDREDS OF UNITS
BEFORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH
AN INFILL DEVELOPMENTS. IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
PROTECTIONS OF HISTORIC
RESOURCES FOUND IN THE
REDEVELOPMENT PLANS WILL NOT BE
REMOVED WITH THE PASSAGE OF
THIS BILL. HISTORIC RESOURCE
PROTECTIONS ARE BEING
INCORPORATED INTO THE CITY'S
NEWLY ADOPTED COMMUNITY PLANS
WHICH ARE BEING UPDATED RIGHT
NOW THESE PROTECTIONS WILL BE
IN PLACE LONG AFTER THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE CURRENT
REDEVELOPMENT PLANS EXPIRE. AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM'S OFFICE.
TO RESOLVE ANY OUTSTANDING
ISSUES. THIS IS A TIME TO THIS.
THE REMAINING REDEVELOPMENT
PLANS HAVE REQUIREMENTS FOR AN
AGENCY THAT THE STATE TO SOLVE
NEARLY A DECADE AGO. NOW THE
SAME PLANS WHICH WERE CREATED
TO REMOVE BLIGHT AND CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAVE BEEN
WEAPONIZED AGAINST THOSE
OBJECTIVES. THIS BILL WOULD
GREATLY ADVANCE OUR EFFORTS TO
MEET OUR CURRENT NEEDS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
BORK- ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF C. NINE
HERE IN THE GALLERY. OPERATOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR AB.
EIGHT THIRTY TWO. BURKE
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I SEE
NONE IN THE GALLERY. OPERATOR
OPPOSITION FOR AB EIGHT THIRTY
TWO IF I BELIEVE WE'RE LOOKING
FOR A FRIEND OFFENHAUSER. FAN
RANDY MARTIN. FRAN OFTEN HOUSES
LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU AMRAN
MARTIN'S LINE IS OPEN AS WELL.
PLEASE PROCEED. THE MANAGER WAS
RAND MARTIN I'LL GO AHEAD AND
JUMP IN THE SILENT- GRANT
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND IT'S
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION WE
APPRECIATE- MISTER WILLIAMS
COMMENTS- IN HIS OPENING
RELATIVE TO HELPING COACH SAID
HELP HELP THE SAFETY CODE
SECTION THREE THREE FOUR ONE
THREE I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO POINT OUT WHY INCLUDING THAT
SECTION IN THE BILL AS IT'S
CURRENTLY WRITTEN- IS A
PROFOUND CONCERN TO US- IT- IT
WOULD- ALLOW THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES TO- TO NO LONGER PURSUE
WHICH RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE
THAT CITIZENS. IN THOSE
REDEVELOPMENT PLAN AREAS HAVE
SOME ASSURANCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WILL BE AVAILABLE- IT
WOULD IT WOULD PUT THE CITY IN
A POSITION NO LONGER NEEDING TO
PAY ATTENTION TO LOW INCOME
HOUSING- IN THOSE PLAN AREAS A
TIME THAT LA HAS THE HIGHEST
HOMELESS RATE- IN THE STATE AND
THE 30% OF ANGELENOS ARE PAYING
MORE THAN HALF OF THEIR INCOME
ON RENT OF YOUR PORTAL HOUSING
NEED IN LOS ANGELES IS GREAT AS
IT IS ACROSS THIS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND WILL TAKE EVERY
EFFORT TO MEET THAT NEED NOW IS
NOT THAT WOULD NOT BE THE TIME
TO RETREAT FROM THE RETREAT
FROM ANY OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
HOUSING FOR OUR LOWEST INCOME
CITIZENS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE AMENDMENTS THAT AYE
MR BLOOM WILL BE PRESENTING- AS
THE BILL MOVES TO THE FLOOR AND
LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING OUR
POSITION AT THAT TIME THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
MARTIN HIS FRIEND. OFFENHAUSER
AVAILABLE. MADAM WE SHOW THAT.
FRAN OFTEN. HOW DROP A LOT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY OTHERS YEAH
OPERATORS OR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO A B.
EIGHT THIRTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
FIFTY ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE LINE. THANK YOU.
ONE
MORE MOMENT PLEASE. AN OUTLINE
NINETY EIGHT YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. DOROTHY RIGHT L.
A. COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY CHAIR
STRONGLY OPPOSE IN THE HALF OF
THE EIGHTY ESPECIALLY THE FORTY
THOUSAND DEMOCRATS VOTED FOR ME.
THANK YOU. I WAS A CANNOT FIND
ONE HUNDRED. WHITE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT YOUR MIKE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS RICHARD
SHERMAN PRIVATE SYSTEM I AM
CALLING TO OPPOSE AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. AND THAT LINE OF ONE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS JULIET NOT
OFTEN AND I AM A DELEGATE TO
EIGHT AND FROM EIGHTEEN FORTY
THREE AND I AM APPALLED. AT.
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. OR IT'S A. NINE TO FIVE.
WELL I NINETY TAKE CARE MY
COULD OPEN. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS TAMMY CHAPMAN AND
'M HERE TO COMMENT ON EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY TWO. I'M OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL PLEASE VOTE NO ONE
AB. EIGHT THIRTY TWO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I THANK YOU. I
BELIEVE FRANCE LINE SKEWS ME UP
FOR A BELIEVE OF FRAN
OFFENHAUSER HAS TRIED TO GET
BACK ON THE LINE CAN WE VERIFY
PLEASE. SURE ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU. WE HAVE- FRAN
OFFENHAUSER ON THE LINE AND
MIKE IT'S OPEN WELCOME.
FRENULUM FRAN NEARBY COULD OPEN.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND THANK YOU FOR PROCESSING-
MY FRIEND OFTEN HEALTHCARE
CALLING FROM HOLLYWOOD HERITAGE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. HOLLYWOOD IT'S NOT THE
GLITZ IT'S NOT THE GLAMOUR.
TOPIC AND I'M HERE FROM THE
REAL HOLLYWOOD WITH HIS NAME
THREE AND YOUR ROUNDING AREAS
THAT HAVE NINE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN. RECOGNIZED UNDISPUTED
LANDMARK. AND IT'S STILL
EVIDENT. OKAY ALL THOSE DARK.
WELL THE PRICE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM HAS AGREED GIVE A TEN TO
THE HIDDEN PROMPT AND WE'RE
THRILLED GREAT. TODAY'S
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. PLEASE THE
AMENDING THE BILL IF CRITICAL.
WHY I SPEAKING FOR ALL RIGHT
FOR YOUR ACT I'M GONNA START
ARCHITECT FRANK READ. STATION
WHEN THE ST AND LOCAL WORK
NUMBER EIGHT ONLINE. BUT TODAY
IN ADDITION I COLLECTED THE
HOLLYWOOD THE BILL PACKED
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO. AND HAVE
THAT LONG INVOLVEMENT AND CO OF
KERN HOLLYWOOD COMMUNITY. THE
ONLY I THINK OF THE FACT THAT
SECTOR TO COMPARE CAN PLAN
BECAUSE OF HOLLYWOOD. THE
THREE. CHECK YOUR ME IN OUR IF
MEMBER PLAN COULD BE THE MAN
DEAL WITH IT THE THIRTY SEVEN
PM IN THE. NUMBER ONE. HARVEST
DEFECT YOUR BILL OUT OF THE
FIELD. WELL YOU WOULD HAVE
ACTUALLY WE HAVE CALCULATED THE
NUMBER CAN BE GO FOR RENO
INTACT WITHOUT TOUCHING S.
REPORT BUILDING HERE WHEN.
EIGHT FORTY. AMENDMENT GOOD
CLEAR APPEALS. AND ALL LAND USE
THE FUNCTION THAT MAKE IT WAS
ABOUT WITH THE LEGISLATION OF
THE DOWN THE WAR ALL IF YOU
DON'T THE UP I'M REQUIRE THIS
BILL AND A LINK TO BE CLEARER.
AMERICAN REMAIN GRATEFUL PILE
DRIVING SHAKING AND CRACKING
THE BILL. WE ARE THEY CAN'T
FIGHT ANALYZE IN MEDICAID FOR
BUILDING INTO AND HOLLYWOOD
READ ABOUT AREA BUT I THINK.
HAD MADE. YOUR AND YOU'RE BEING
HALF TO CREATE A CONTEMPT THAT
SOLD CAME. APPLE PROTECTION CAP
EVEN FUTURE. I APPRECIATED
PLEASE DON'T ACCEPT THE BLANKET
WEEPING WHITEOUT OF THE GOOD IT
REDEVELOPMENT BROUGHT IN THE
NAME OF THE- SUPPOSED. THE
PROTECTION OF AFFORDABLE HEALTH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
GOING ON ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. LINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
MAKING JACKSON I'M WITH HOUSING
IS A HUMAN RIGHTS WE OPPOSE. AB
EIGHT THIRTY TWO THANK YOU AS
IT STANDS. AND LINE SIXTY THREE
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. HI THIS
IS SWEDISH AND ITALIAN IS HUMAN
RIGHT OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO AND- BASICALLY
BECAUSE IT UNDERMINES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN IRELAND
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WITH THE
LINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN. YEAH YES HELLO MY NAME IS
A LOT OF THE MONTH UNIT. I AM I
AM. IN A POSITION TO.
CALIFORNIA FROM RUBIO FEEL
EIGHT THIRTY TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOODBYE LAKE. AND THE O.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO.
YES MY NAME IS BRIAN COOPER
WITH AN ICON CLASSIC FILM
FESTIVAL AND I AM IN OPPOSITION
OF AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. BLIND NO. ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN. GREETINGS
WELCOME CHAIRMAN IN THE SKILL
IN SILENCE TODAY I'M
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR CLEAN WATER AND
LIABILITY ARE IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO BIT OF
PENSION PAYMENT NEXT WILL
FOLLOW. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IN THE LINE OF ONE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX. YES MY NAME
IS CHERYL AND STAPLETON I
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO
IT'S BAD FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE NEXT. THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE. LINE
ONE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. AND MADAM CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THE TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE OF THE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. OKAY WERE
MOTION BY ROOM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS. OKAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLUBS I THANK MANAGER
AND MEMBERS- LET ME JUST-
ADDRESS A COUPLE OF- ISSUES- AS
I ALREADY DID THE MAIN PART OF
MY REMARKS- THIS BILL DOES NOT
INTEND TO WIPE AWAY AND ANYWAY
HISTORIC DISTRICT TO
PRESERVATION- WE ARE WORKING
WITH HOLLYWOOD HERITAGE- TO
FIND SOLUTIONS TO. THEIR
CONCERNS I HAD A LENGTHY
CONVERSATION WITH MS OFFICE OF
IN HOUSE- A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO
WE HAVE ANOTHER- MY STAFF AS
ANOTHER CALL SCHEDULED ON
FRIDAY SO WE ARE ACTIVELY
WORKING ON THAT ISSUE AND TO
WITH RESPECT. TO THE- IMPACT OF
THE BILL ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AS IT WAS ORIGINALLY PROPOSED-
I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL HOWEVER- WE'VE REMOVED
SECTION THREE THREE FOUR ONE
THREE THAT'S THE SECTION THAT
SHOULD BE OF CONCERN ON THAT
ISSUE AND WILL BE TAKING THOSE
AMOUNTS AS THE BILL COMES TO
THE FLOOR YEAH THANK YOU SOME
MEMBER BLOOM- FOR. BRINGING
THIS FOCUS BILL FOR THE WIND
DOWN OF REDEVELOPMENT PLANS AND
LOS ANGELES IS PARTICULARLY
COMPLEX DUE TO THE COMPLICATED
STRUCTURE OF THE ORIGINAL RDA.
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO CLARIFY THE SCOPE
OF THE SEQUEL EXEMPTION IN THE
BILL AND MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING
CHANGES. I'M PLEASED TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL THAT THAT THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY HI
LACKEY. AYE LACKEY AYE BLOOM HI
WILL I BOERNER HORVATH. RAMOS
RAMOS I THREE OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS HI ROBERT RIVAS I
VOEPEL WITHOUT ALL RIGHT THE
LOTUS SIX ZERO OKAY THE BILLS
THAT WOULD HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADD ONS. OKAY THANK YOU-
WOULD BE TO MOVE BACK IN THE
ORDER AND THEY WILL DO NUMBER
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
WELCOME TO PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU I'M ADAM CHAIR
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH THIS
THIS IS ABOUT- ELECTRIC
VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA CHARGING
STATIONS CHARGING STATIONS IF
YOU WANT TO. MAKE A MARK AND
GET TO A CLEAN ENERGY
CALIFORNIA AND TACKLE CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THAT ERROR WE NEED
TO STEP IT UP RELATED TO-
CHARGING STATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A NUMBER
OF VEHICLES ON THE ROAD. I
WOULD LIKE TO START OFF BY
EXPECTED ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR STAFF TO WORKING
ON THIS ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
LATER BY THINK THIS ADDRESS IS
A BIG PART OF IT. SIX YEARS
AGO. THE STATE- PASSED A LAW TO
STREAMLINETHE PERMITTING
PROCESS TO BUILD. HEAVEY
CHARGING STATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER IT REALLY
HASN'T HAPPENED AS WE HAD
HOPED. I RESEARCH THE LAST FEW
WEEKS FOUND THAT JUST. ABOUT A
QUARTER OF OUR JURISDICTIONS.
ARE FOLLOWING THE LAW WHEN IT
COMES TO STREAMLINING.
PERMITTING AND THIS BILL. WILL
FOCUS ON COMPLIANCE TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN RESOLVE. THESE
ISSUES THAT WE MUST TAKE
IMMEDIATE STEPS TO BUILD OUT
CHARGING STATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT EV'S. AND TO MEET OUR
AIR QUALITY AND CLIMATE GOALS.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. I THINK
THIS BILL DOES THAT. IT'S NOT A
GUARANTEE THAT THESE THINGS
WILL BE BUILT IT JUST WITH-
MOTIVATE. I JURISDICTIONS TO DO
THE RIGHT THING. THAT THEY DO
DRAG THEIR FEET IT WOULD SET
SOME. TIME LINES FOR. A SWIFT
ACTION AS FAR AS COMPLIANCE
WITH APPLICATIONS FOR THESE TV
CHARGING STATIONS. I WITH ME R.
I. TO SUPPORTERS AND I WOULD
ASK THE RIVAL THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE HAVE-
BILL MEGA BURNED HERE IN THE
OFFICE FOR THEM AND IN THE
GALLERY FOR SUPPORT. AND THEN
WE ALSO MATTHEW NELSON I
BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO BE COMING
ON THE PHONE. IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE THANK YOU THINK OUT OF
YOUR BILL. WITH THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR INTO. OF AB NINE
SEVEN ZERO. CALIFORNIA
CONFRONTS THE TWIN CRISES OF
AIR POLLUTION AND CLIMATE
CHANGE AIR POLLUTION KILLS
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS.
EVERY YEAR AND SECONDS MANY
OTHERS. OF THE SOUTH COAST
REGION AS THE WORST SMOG IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY. THE SAN JOAQUIN
REGION HAS THE WORST PARTICLE
POLLUTION IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO
THE BAY AREA. HAVE ALL FAILED
TO ACHIEVE. NATIONALLY
REQUIRED. AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS. AND WE SEE EVERY DAY
THE EFFECTS OF THE CLIMATE
CRISIS WITH WILDFIRES. DROUGHT
HEAT WAVES AND RISING SEA
LEVEL. THE GOOD NEWS IS- THAT
WE HAVE A SOLUTION TO THE
BIGGEST SOURCE OF THE EMISSIONS
THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF EMISSIONS
THAT CAUSE AIR POLLUTION AND
pTRANSPORTATION SECTOR. AND WE
CAN CLEAN THAT UP BY ELECTRIFY.
OUR VEHICLES ARE CARS TRUCKS
AND BUSES- AND BECAUSE OF THAT.
WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE- NEED TO
HAVE WIDESPREAD ACCESSIBLE.
CONVENIENT CHARGING. IN ORDER
TO ELECTRIFY TRANSPORTATION.
AND THE LEGISLATURE SAW. THAT
NEED AND IN TWENTY FIFTH.
PASSED AB TWO THIRTY SO BY SOME
WE MAY DAVID CHIU ROCK. LOCAL
TO. THE PERMITTING FOR. ON WE
HAVEN'T BEEN KEEPING UP WE HAVE
A CHARGING GAP THE ENERGY
COMMISSION ESTIMATES THAT BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WILL BE
SHORT SIXTY TWO THOUSAND.
CHARGERS AT OUR CURRENT RATE.
AND WITHOUT THERE'S A LACK OF
COMPLIANCE WITH AB TWELVE
THIRTY SIX. GOBIZ WHICH HAD A
GOAL OF A 100% COMPLIANCE BY
EARTH DAY OF LAST MONTH. HAS
FOUND THAT ONLY 25% OF
JURISDICTIONS ARE COMPLYING
WITH THIS LAW THAT WAS ENACTED
ALMOST SIX YEARS AGO SO YOU'LL
HEAR MORE ABOUT THE SPECIFICS
FROM THE NEXT WITNESS. MATT
NELSON AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH HOME
RUN TO FROM MATTHEW NELSON.
HE'S ON THE PHONE OPERATOR. HI
THE PLAN IS NOT MATTHEW NELSON
CAN YOU ALL HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
CORRECT JEROD YOUR CURRY VICE
CHAIR LACKEY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MATTHEW
NELSON AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND
ELECTRIFY AMERICA I REACHED
RIGHTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINE SEVENTY ELECTRIFY
AMERICA IS THE LARGEST AND
FASTEST GROWING NETWORK OF
ULTRA FAST CHARGING STATIONS IN
THE UNITED STATES SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE'VE ADDED
STATIONS AT A PACE OF
APPROXIMATELY FOUR PER WEEK
LAST WEEK WE CELEBRATED THE
OPENING OF OUR SIX HUNDRED
STATION ACROSS FORTY SIX STATES
AND CALIFORNIA IS BY FAR OUR
LARGEST MARKET WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
STATIONS. HERE IN CALIFORNIA
OPERATIONAL TODAY. CALIFORNIA'S
EVEY CHARGING STATION CARMEN IN
LAW ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER
CHOOSE AB TWELVE THIRTY SIX. IT
IS THE STRONGEST EVEY PERMIT
EXPEDITING LAW IN THE NATION.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT FOLLOWED
AND IT'S NOT ENFORCED. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THE AVERAGE
TIME TO COMPLETE THE PERMITTING
PROCESS FOR A DC FAST CHARGING
STATIONS. IN CALIFORNIA ROSE
FROM SEVENTY FIVE BUSINESS DAYS
TO SEVENTY SEVEN BUSINESS DAYS.
MAKING THAT 38% LONGER THAN OUR
NATIONAL AVERAGE. PERMITTING
PROCESS HE'S ALSO RESULT IN
STATION SITE SITES BEING
REDESIGNED MORE FREQUENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA THAN THE REST OF THE
NATION. WHICH INCREASES COSTS
AND LEADS TO DELAYS. IN INC. IT
COSTS ELECTRIFY AMERICA ABOUT
32% MORE ON AVERAGE TO DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCT A STATION IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS EXACTLY THE
SAME FEATURES EXACTLY THE SAME
NUMBER OF CHARGERS WHEN
COMPARED TO ANY OTHER STATE.
THE HIGHER COSTS PER STATION
ULTIMATELY MEAN THAT CALIFORNIA
WILL RECEIVE FEWER STATIONS PER
DOLLAR INVESTED BY ELECTRIFY
AMERICA AND EVERY OTHER
INVESTOR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE.
ADDITIONALLY AS AS BILL JUST
MENTIONED A REVIEW BY
GOVERNOR'S MEANS THAT
INDONESIAN STAFF I GO THIS IS
FOUND THAT ONLY 2524225% OF
CALIFORNIA JURISDICTIONS ARE
COMPLYING WITH AB TWELVE THIRTY
SIX. AS OF RIGHT NOW IN OUR
EXPERIENCE OUR PRIMARY CAUSES
OF DELAY INCLUDE EXTENDED
ZONING REVIEW PARKING COUNT
REQUIREMENTS AND MULTIPLE
ROUNDS OF COMMENTS ALL OF WHICH
ARE PROHIBITED BY AT TWELVE
THIRTY SIX. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
IMPLEMENTED APPROVING PERMIT
EXPEDITING STRATEGY WELL KNOWN
IN CALIFORNIA THE PERMIT
STREAMLINING ACCESS USED IN
COMPLETE CONCEPT SINCE THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND AB FIFTY
SEVEN HAS IMPLEMENTED DEEMED
APPROVED STRUCTURES- IN THE
TELECOM SPACE SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN WITH VERY POSITIVE
RESULTS. ON BEHALF OF ELECTRIFY
AMERICA I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
THE LEADERSHIP ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MCCARTY AND CHEW ON THIS ISSUE
BEEN WORKING ON A VERY LONG
TIME AND DESERVE OUR THANKS. I
WANT TO THANK THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR FOR RECOGNIZING THAT
SIXTEEN PERMITTING HAS- A
CRITICAL ROLE IN HELPING US
SHARE RECHARGE SHARED
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. AND I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR AND STAFF
FOR THEIR GUIDANCE AND
ASSISTANCE IN MAKING THIS THE
BEST POSSIBLE BILL I THINK
WE'VE GOTTEN. TO A BETTER PLACE
THANKS TO YOUR FEEDBACKAND
INPUT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOU TO VOTE I- TODAY AND I'M
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER NELSON LET'S MOVE ON.
OPERATOR. TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. FOR COMMONSENSE OF AB
NINE SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE ZERO. BLIND NINETY
FOUR YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS DEALING
JACKPOT BEHALF OF VALLEY CLEAN
AIR NOW IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS COLOR
JOAQUIN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
UTILITY EMPLOYEES AND
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNTRY
COUNCIL EXPRESSING OUR SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFETT ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE IN INNOVATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE SEVENTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
UNDRED SIXTY FOUR. HI THE
SUBJECT MATTER WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP WE
PREVIOUSLY HAD A SUPPORT
AMENDED POSITION AND ONE I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR CAPPING A
COMMITMENT MENTOR NOW IN FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE. LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS CAPPING LUNCH
REPRESENTING PLUG IN AMERICA
CONSUMER ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHITE. ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN. HELLO HELLO HELLO
HELLO YOUR MIKE IT OPENLY. I'M
ALL MEMBERS COUNCIL CANNELLA IS
GENTLER THAN THEIR CREDIT
TWENTY MINUTES TWENTY IN TWENTY
EIGHT TO THE LATE. ABBY ALSO
BELIEVE THOSE. THANK YOU NOT
BELIEVE I. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MEDICARE
MEMBERS DAN CHAU WITH TESLA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY THREE. MY NAME
CHAIR MEMBERS AND YOUR EMPLOYEE
WAS TRYING TO ARRANGE WHICH
RUNS AROUND LYING- IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE SEVENTY MCCARTY ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI. THANK YOU. AND.
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY ONE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THOMAS LAWSON WITH
FORD MOTOR COMPANY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I CANNOT
LINE EIGHTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ROD BREWER WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE SEVENTY.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NONE IN THE
GALLERY OF OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE- EXCUSE ME MORE
COMMENTS IN. I DO HAVE EXCUSE
ME I'D LIKE TO BACK UP. I DO
HAVE ONE THIS IS OPPOSITION
THOUGH BE TRACY RYAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- TO SPEAK. I APOLOGIZE
TO MYSTERON. NO PROBLEM GOOD
AFTERNOON TRACY RYAN WITH THE
WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTS A
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES THE
URBAN COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA AND
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES- RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY WE DO APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT QUITE SEVEN AMENDMENT TO
IMPROVE THE WORKABILITY OF THE
BILL- HOWEVER REMAIN CONCERNED
WITH THE DEEMED APPROVED
COMMITTINGNOT ONLY WHAT IT
UNFAIRLY PRIORITIZED ET
CHARGING APPLICATIONS OVER
ORDER PERMITS. IN THIS CASE IT
WOULD APPLY TO ALL LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING THOSE
THAT COMPLY WITH THE EASY EASY
STREAMLINING PER AB TWELVE
THIRTY SIX REGRETTABLY EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY PLACES UNTENABLE
BURDEN ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
CREATE A SEPARATE IN AN EQUAL.
PERMITTING AND INSPECTION
PROCESS. WE FOR EVEY CHARGE
STATION. WE RESPECTFULLY WHERE
ANOTHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RENTS FOR OKAY DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
NECROMANTIC IN. ONE NINE ZERO.
INCLINED ONE HUNDRED FORTY TWO
YEAR MIKE IS UP- YES MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
RUSSELL NOW ACT ON BEHALF OF
CAL THE PC I WAS IN THE OTHER
CATEGORY- COUNTY T. T. AS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE
SEVENTY THANKS SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. AND THAT LINE OF. ONE
HUNDRED SIXTEEN. THANK YOU
BRADY HEARING AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
TO EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY DUE TO
SAFETY CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IN IT WE HAVE ONE
MORE COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE NUMBER. IN
LINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY YEAR
MY KIDS UP. I YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR HEIDI
STRICKLER HAD A POLICY AND TO
POWER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINE SEVEN E. STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE QUESTION
FROM POSTAL REMEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH- YES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING FOR
THIS FELLOW- WE SPOKE EARLIER
THIS MORNING AND I IMMEDIATELY
CONTACTED TO MY CITIES WHO IN
THAT. GOBIZ MOP OR READ BOTH
CITY MANAGERS WERE LIKE OH
SORRY WE CAN FIX THIS NOW- SO I
DO THINK THERE IS A MESS I
DISAGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION
THAT THIS IS UNTENABLE I SPOKE
WITH- THE ONE OF THE- PLANNING
OFFICERS AND SEND IT IS. ANY
SAID GENERALLY WE DO IT WITHOUT
THE STREAMLINING BUT WE
GENERALLY PROVE THEM ON THE
BUILDING PERMIT SIDE- WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS SO COMPLYING WITH
THIS THE BILL WOULD ABSOLUTELY
NOT BE A PROBLEM FOR EITHER OF
THE TWO CITIES. SO I THINK IT
IS GOOD THAT WE BRING IT
FORWARD- WE DO NEED EASY FAST
CHARGING NETWORKS AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM OUR
CONVERSATION THAT IF THE CITY
NEEDS TO HAVE LIKE A DO A
TRAFFIC ANALYSIS THEY HAVE
THOSE FIVE DAYS TO DO A
COMPLETE AND TWENTY DAYS. TO
MAKE THOSE FINDINGS TO THE TO
HAVE THE FURTHER ANALYSIS.
CORRECT IT. GOOD YEAH EVEN. IT
JUST SAYS IF THE- SITS THERE.
FOR FIVE DAYS AND YOU DON'T
RESPOND THE APPLICATIONS A
COMPLETE APPLICATION AND THEN
THERE'S TWENTY DAYS TO REVIEW
IT SO THAT TWENTY DAYS IF THEY
SIDE VIEW WE ADDRESS SOME
PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES. THEN THEY CAN TRIGGER
EVEN MORE TIME TO DO THAT WORK
THEY JUST CAN'T SIT ON IT FOR
THAT TIME YEAH SO I THINK IT'S
IS- REASONABLE THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE SO MUCH SUPPORT THERE WAS
SOME OPPOSITE FROM THE SMALLER
CITIES AND I THINK WITH THE
AMENDMENTS FOR. GIVING THEM
MORE TIME TO DO SO IN MANY
RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE DOING
THIS AND IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
COSTLY BECAUSE THE DEVELOPERS
ASK YOU COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT YOU PAY IT OUT YOU
PAY A FEE SO THESE ARE FEE
BASED PROGRAM IS NOT SUPPORTED
BY THE GENERAL FUND. ALL
PRIVATE DEVELOPMENT AS THE
PLANNING FEE AND THAT GOES TO
PAY FOR THE FOR THE SERVICES
FOR THE PLANNING DEPARTMENT AS
WELL YES SO I THINK MY CITIES
WILL BE COMPLYING AHEAD OF THIS
BILL GETTING OUT OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND THROUGH THE SENATE
TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DESK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
AFFORD ALL THE SUPPORTING TODAY.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SAYING NONE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS. NEED A SECOND. I
HAVE A SECOND BY US ON MEMBER
RAMOS. OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I THINK YOU APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION THIS IS A BIG
PRIORITY ACROSS OUR STATE AND
NATION FEDERALIZING BECOMING IN
THROUGH PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
INITIATIVE TO FOR MORE CHARGING
STATIONS THIS WILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THEM THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND THEN THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS. ARE DEPLOYING EVEY
CHARGING STATIONS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE HAS BEEN THE POLICY OF
THE STATE PRINT QUIZSTAR QUITE
A LONG TIME. WELL WE DO NEED TO
BE MINDFUL OF LOCAL CONTROL AND
THE ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES HEY
DEEMED REPROVED APPROACH
PRESENTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE
ALSO NEED THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT THE VIS I BELIEVE THIS
BILL STRIKES A REASONABLE
BALANCE AND WE'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I
BLACKIE. LACKEY I BLEW. WELL
FIVE BURNER. BOERNER HORVATH I.
RAMOS RAMOS I LIVED.
ROBERT RIVAS HI ROBERT
RIVERSIDE REPEL. HI VOEPEL I
HAVE SEVEN ZERO OKAY THE BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL OPEN PRINT OUT ON. OKAY
LET'S WELCOME ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB SEVEN SUPPOSED TO USE ME
THANKS AB EIGHT NINE FIVE NINE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. I GOT AHEAD
OF MYSELF MISTER MULLIN. THANK
YOU GOVERNOR WELCOME. M.
MEMBERS PRESENTING. AB DIED
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU FOR THAT
FOR A START UP BY SEVEN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS OUTLINED
IN COMMON NUMBER SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS AND I WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THE MEASURE AB KNIFE
IT DID I WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW
INDEPENDENT PARK DISTRICTS TO
BE ABLE TO EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS A MULTITUDE
OF PUBLIC NUISANCES. THAT THEY
CONFRONT REGULARLY SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL WOULD GIVE THE STATE'S
FOR INDEPENDENT PARK DISTRICT'S
PUBLIC NUISANCE ABATEMENT
AUTHORITY WITHIN ITS PRINCIPAL
ACTS SIMILAR TO A CITY OR
COUNTY'S ABILITY SPECIFICALLY
THE PARK DISTRICTS WOULD HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DECLARE BY
ORDINANCE WHAT CONSTITUTES A
PUBLIC NUISANCE THE AUTHORITY
TO ABATE THOSE PUBLIC NUISANCES
BY EITHER ADMINISTRATIVE OR
CIVIL ACTIONS THE ABILITY TO
RECOVER ITS COSTS INCURRED IN
ABATING THE PUBLIC NUISANCE
INCLUDING ATTORNEY'S FEES. IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR PARK DISTRICT
STAFF TO BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESS ILLEGAL ENCROACHMENTS
ON A PARK DISTRICTS PROPERTY
WITHOUT A FULL SET OF TOOLS AT
THE PARK DISTRICTS DISPOSAL
THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE
PUBLIC LANDS ARE NOT GETTING
THE PROTECTION THEY NEED
EXAMPLES OF THESE NUISANCES-
CAN RUN THROUGH UP A LEGAL
WATER DIVERSION EXTENSION OF
YARDS IN A PARK HABITAT ILLEGAL
DUMPING AND GRADING ON
AUTHORIZED LANDSCAPING AND
LEGAL- STREAMBED ALTERATION ALL
OF WHICH MAY IMPACT SENSITIVE
HABITAT WILDFIRE PROTECTION
ZONES. AND OTHER PARK SPECIFIC
USES THESE DISTRICTS UP NEED TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS ILLEGAL
ENCROACHMENTS IN THE SAME
COMPREHENSIVE WAY THE OTHER
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENTITIES DO AS
WELL- GIVEN THAT PURCHASERS ARE
BEST SUITED TO ADDRESS LAND
STEWARDSHIP AND MANAGEMENT
ISSUES ON ITS OWN LANDS
PROVIDING PARK DISTRICTS WITH
THE APPROPRIATE ABATEMENT TOOLS
WOULD BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
ALLOCATION OF PUBLIC RESOURCES
THIS MEASURE HAS NO OPPOSITION.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE I HAVE
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE- IN
SUPPORT CHASIN ROSENBERG WITH-
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
AND HILARY STEPHENSON WITH MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT. IN MY NECK OF THE
WOODS AND I ASKED FOR THE I
FELT THANK YOU WILL HAVE A- IN
SUPPORT CAN WE PLEASE GET JEEZ-
ROSENBERG PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MAY AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY THE PRIMARY
WITNESS MY NAME IS JASON
ROSENBERG AND I SERVED AS
ASSISTANT DISTRICT COUNCIL FOR
THE EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT. THESE BAY REGIONAL
PARK DISTRICT OF THE MULTI
COUNTY REGIONAL PARK AND OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT CREATED UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RESOURCES
CODE. A CORE FUNCTION OF THE
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
LIKE ANY PARK DISTRICT IF THE
STEWARDSHIP OF ITS NATURAL
RESOURCES. THIS RESPONSIBILITY
HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY
CRITICAL GIVEN THE PRESSING
NEED TO ADDRESS THE CHANGING
CLIMATE. PART DISTRICTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PLANNING
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE WITH
OF THIS SYSTEM OF PARK LANDS
HOWEVER BECAUSE PART DISTRICTS
DO NOT HAVE LAND USE POWER IT
LIKE CITIES AND COUNTIES THE
LEGAL TOOLS. THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO PREVENT UNAUTHORIZED USES OF
PARK LANDS ARE STRICTLY LIMITED
TO THOSE GRANTED TO US BY
STATUTE. IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF
WHERE PARK DISTRICT STATUTORY
GRABBED ALREADY OF LIMITED
COMPARED TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
IS IN FACT NUISANCE ABATEMENT.
IT IS FOR THIS REASON I'M
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN BILL AB NINE FIVE
NINE. IF THIS BLL BECOMES LAW
IT WOULD PROVIDE THE PARK
DISTRICT WITH A VALUABLE TOOL
TO EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
MANAGES PARKLANDS. HAVING THE
ABILITY TO ADMINISTRATIVELY
OBEY ILLEGAL ENCROACHMENTS THAT
EXIST ON PARK DISTRICT PROPERTY
WOULD IN COMPARISON BE COST
EFFECTIVE AND HELP THE PARK
DISTRICT EFFICIENTLY CARRY OUT
A PLAN STORAGE OF MISSION. THE
GOAL WITH THE BEATEN POWER
WOULD BE USED TO USE IT AS A
LAST RESORT WITH THE INTENT TO
HAVE IT FUNCTION AS A DETERRENT
INDIVIDUALS ARE CONDUCTING
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES ON THE PARK
DISTRICT PROPERTY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR ROSENBERG WE
ARE LOOKING FOR MISS STEVENSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS HILLARY
STEPHENSON. GENERAL COUNSEL FOR
THE MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT. ALSO KNOWN AS
THE TANNERS. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU
TODAY IN SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY
NINE FIVE NINE. MID PENN OWNS
AND MANAGES TWENTY SIX OPEN
SPACE PRESERVE THROUGHOUT THE
GREATER SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS
REGION. OUR DISTRICTS CANCEL
PORTIONS OF THREE COUNTIES AND
SEVENTEEN THIRTY. AND ALTHOUGH
WE PROACTIVELY COORDINATE AND
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR NEIGHBORS
PROBLEMS OCCASIONALLY ARISE
SOME REAL LIFE EXAMPLES OF
ISSUES THAT WE COULD ADDRESS
VIA A NEWSGROUP ABATEMENT
PROCESS RANGE FROM ILLEGAL
TRAIL AND ROAD CONSTRUCTION ON
THE HANLAN'S AND DISPOSAL OF
CUT VEGETATION WHICH CREATES A
FIRE RISK. TO SOME MORE UNUSUAL
SITUATION. SUCH AS AN OPERATOR
FOR A LLAMA ENCLOSURE AND A
BOCCE BALL COURT ENCROACHING ON
Q. BELLA KITCHEN MADE PENALTIES
OR SLAM. WITHOUT YOU CAN THE
BASEMENT ALSO. MIDTOWN ADDRESS
INCREASE. THROUGH THE CRIMINAL
PROCESS OUR RANGERS ISSUE
CITATIONS OR REFER MORE SERIOUS
MATTERS TO CRIMINAL COURT AND
IN RECENT YEARS AND HOW
PREFERRED TO CRIMINAL CASES
SHE'S THE LOCAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR PROSECUTION BOTH
OF THOSE CASES HAVE POPPED ME
FIRST ILLEGALLY DIVERTED WATER
OTHER PROTECTED CREEK ON THE
PAR LANDS FOR UNAUTHORIZED. USE
ON PRIVATE PROPERTY.
PROSECUTION THE CASE CLOSE MORE
THAN A YEAR FROM TIME THAT WE
FIRST DETECTED A VIOLATION AND
UNFORTUNATELY EVEN AFTER
RECEIVING RESTITUTION THE
CRIMINAL PROCESS DOES NOT MAKE
MID PENN HOLE FOR THE COSTS AND
THE RANGER AND STAFF TIED
NECESSARY TO COMMAND. A
CRIMINAL ACTION AND STEVE THAT
PROCEEDING THROUGH TO
CONCLUSION SO SIMPLY PUT WE'RE
LYING ON THE CRIMINAL PROCESS
CONFUSED. LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES THE COURT RESOURCES
AND UNFORTUNATELY IT DOESN'T
HAUNT ME ADDRESS THE CONDITION.
SO THE HOPE IS THAT EIGHTY NINE
FIVE NINE WHAT IF ARE YOU SEE
MY OF HOW. IN OUR FORCES. AND
ALLOW ME TO ABATEMENT
PROCEEDINGS OCCUR MINUTES. TO A
MORE FISH RISK. YOUR VOTE IN
FAVOR OF NINE FIVE NINE WOULD
ENABLE MADE. TO DELIVER TO
CREEK FINANCIAL WATER. PRESERVE
NATURAL. REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK
AND PROTECT PUBLIC ACCESS TO
OUR PRESERVES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
STEVENSON LET'S MOVE ON TO THIS
AND I DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE THE
GALLERY TO SUPPORT OPERATOR OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
MARK COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AT THE END ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. ONE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE YEAR MIKE
IS UP. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO YEAR MIKE IS UP.
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS ANTHONY
PARALLEL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR WERE LOOKING
UP FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I DON'T HAVE ANYONE LISTED-
THERE'S NO ONE THAT APPEARS TO
BE IN THE GALLERY. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE PLEASE. FOR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO IT A. B. NINE
FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
THERE ANY ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SEEING NINE I HAVE A
MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AND I'VE GOT A
SECOND BYE BYE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
ASK FOR LIVE OAK OKAY THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN FOR WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON THE BILL
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHAT'S UP WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I. LACKEY. LACKEY
I BLOOM BLOOM ARBOR HARDBACK
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS ALMOST
NINE TWO THREE THIS THREE OF US
HI ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL. WHAT HIGH
EIGHT THE VILLAGE OUT- I DON'T
WANT TO EVERYBODY CHIPS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO ITEM NUMBER NINE
SB SEVEN SEVEN THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND NAZARIAN PROCEED
WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES-
PROBABLY PRESENTING AB SEVEN
SEVEN THREE THIS BILL SIMPLY
AUTHORIZES LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO
MAKE TEMPORARY SLOW STREETS
PERMANENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IN ADDITION AB SEVEN SEVEN
THREE AUTHORIZES LOCAL
AUTHORITIES TO ADOPT A RULE OR
REGULATION TO DESIGNATE A LOCAL
STREET WITHIN ITS JURISDICTION
AS A SLOW STREET- SIMILAR TO
OTHER CITIES ACROSS THE NATION
AND ABROAD REPURCHASING STREETS
TO REPRIORITIZE COMMUNITY
NEEDS. HAS BEEN A WINNING
CONCEPT CREATING MORE OPEN
SPACE FOR BICYCLING WALKING
WHILE INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR RECREATION THIS CAME ABOUT
LAST YEAR IN- IN OAKLAND IN
EARLY APRIL TWENTY TWENTY- AND
THE IDEA WAS TO IDENTIFY
STREETS WERE THROUGH TRAFFIC
WOULD BE BANNED FOR LIMITING
SPEEDS SO PEOPLE COULD USE
PAVEMENT FOR EXERCISE DURING.
THE TIME OF COVE IT IT'S BEEN
SO SIX THECITY OF LOS ANGELES
WITH LIKE TO MAKE IT PER. FOR
ITS REST. SO WITH THAT I WAS
ASK FOR YOU AYE VOTE BUT THE
THAT I AM JOINED BY JULIE
SELENA WITH THE MAYOR CITIES
RATE FOR WITNESSES SUPPORT I
MISS. IF YOU'D LIKE TO US FOR
THE PHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON- YOU
MADAM CHAIR VICE. AND MEMBERS
OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS JULIA
SALINAS TRANSPORTATION MANAGER
IN THE OFFICE OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI- AND THINK
YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAY
VARIANT. WHERE PROUD TO SPONSOR
AB SEVEN SEVEN THREE WHICH
GIVES CITIES THE ABILITY TO
PRIORITIZE NEIGHBORHOOD STREETS
FOR COMMUNITIES- JUST OVER A
YEAR AGO KOBE NINETEEN. FOURTH
CALIFORNIANS TO STAY HOME FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH SAFETY AND WITH
STREETS CALM FROM STAY IN STATE
HOME ORDERS AND COMMUNITIES IN
NEED OF SAFE SPACES TO GET
OUTSIDE CLOSE TO HOME. CITIES
ACROSS THE STATE ACROSS THE
NATION IN WORLD LUNCH PROGRAMS
SIMILAR TO OURS CALLED SLOW
STREET- IN LA THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION WORKED WITH
COMMUNITIES TO INSTALL. INSTALL
CLOSE TREES ON APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY MILES OF NEIGHBORHOOD
STREETS. THIS LOW STREETS
PROGRAM IN LA WITH A TRUE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND SPONSORING
COMMUNITY GROUPS WHO VOLUNTEER
THEIR OWN TIME TO MONITOR THESE
TEMPORARY INSTALLATIONS. ARE
PROGRAM LAUNCHED IN MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND ALMOST ALL
ARE STILL IN PLACE TODAY. IN LA
THREE OF US HAS BEEN A REALLY
POPULAR PROGRAMS WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN UNABLE TO MEET THE DEMAND
OF COMMUNITIES WITH THE
TEMPORARY PROGRAM AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE THE
EXISTING INSTALLATIONS. MORE
PERMANENT. AB SEVEN SEVENTY
WILL PRO CITY WITH THE TOOL TO
MAKE FLOWS MORE PERMANENT AND
WILL ALLOW CITIES TO CREATE A
LOCAL ORDINANCE THAT WILL ALLOW
STREETS TO BE CLOSED TO THROUGH
TRAFFIC. AND TO BE CLEAR THIS
WOULD ONLY BE ON NEIGHBORHOOD
STREETS. THERE WOULD NOT BE ANY
COMMERCIAL CORRIDOR IMPACT AND
IT WOULD NOT AFFECT PARKING AND
WOULD NOT AFFECT TRAVELING.
THIS CHANGE WOULD NEVER PREVENT
ANYONE FROM ACCESSING A LOCAL
STREET IF THEY NEEDED TO. ADD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MISLEAD THIS
LET'S MOVE ON TO OTHERS. IN
SUPPORT OF SEEING NO ONE HERE
IN THE GALLERY. OPERATOR. FOUR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
SEVEN SEVEN THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT TO BE
AVENUE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I SEE NONE HERE IN THE GALLERY.
OPERATOR ON THE LINE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. FOR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
SEVEN SEVEN THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE THEN. ZERO AND WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THE TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I DON'T SEE ANY SO
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH AND THEN
WE HAVE A SECOND FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LUCKY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SPEC
CLASS FOR ADULTS THANK YOU AND
I- THANKS FOR BRINGING IT TO
PROMOTE YOUR BILL TO. PROMOTE
THE ADOPTION OF MORE SLOW
STREETS ARE STAY. WITH RULES
AND REGULATIONS ADOPTED BY
ORDINANCE RESOLUTION THAT THE
BILL REQUIRES THESE NEW
DESIGNATION SHOULD TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF EACH
NEIGHBORHOOD I'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL THE DAY. MOTIONS. TO
PASS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I AGUIAR-CURRY. LACKEY
AYE FLAG I BLOOM. ROOM AYE
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I ROMMEL'S.
ROLES I'D LOSE RIVAS. RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS. ROBERT RIVAS PAL
RIGHT. EIGHT ZERO HE BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. OKAY MEMBERS ARE
DOWN TO OUR LAST ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN BUYER COMMITTEE AT AB
THREE SIXTY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS. PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
COMMITTEE NOW SIS AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS- CREATE THOSE- AND
THIS LEGISLATION PROPOSES TO
GRANT LOCAL AGENCIES OR
LEGISLATIVE BODIES THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE WITH THE FLEXIBILITY
TO MEET REMOTELY. AND TO ME
REMOTELY- IN TIMES OF
EMERGENCIES THAT WOULD INHIBIT
IN PERSON GATHERINGS AND ENSURE
A PUBLIC ACCESS OR YOU KNOW-
WOULD WOULD REQUIRE OR REPUBLIC
ACCESS THAT- THE PUBLIC BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
MEETINGS I SHOULD THEY BE
NECESSARY- VIA A TELEPHONE OR
VIDEO CONFERENCE YOU KNOW AS WE
ALL KNOW LAST YEAR THE
BEGINNING OF THE PUBLIC NINETY
PANDEMIC. OUR GOVERNOR ISSUED-
MANY EXECUTIVE ORDERS- BUT SOME
IN PARTICULAR THAT GRANTED
LOCAL AGENCIES TEMPORARILY FOR
THE DAY FOR THE DURATION OF THE
THIS CURRENT STATE OF EMERGENCY
AMID THIS PANDEMIC THE ABILITY
TO MEET REMOTELY- AND FOR THE
PUBLIC TO HAVE ACCESS TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY- IT'S A
CLEARLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WERE
IN NEED OF THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER
I TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO HOLD PUBLIC MEETINGS.
AMID THIS PANDEMIC ON TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES LIKE FIRE PROTECTION
WATER AND UTILITIES- WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY TAKING NECESSARY
ACTIONS DUE TO THIS ONGOING-
THIS PANDEMIC AND SO THIS BILL
BUILDS ON LESSONS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED- YOU KNOW I'M IN THE
PAST FOURTEEN MONTHS. THIS IS
THAT HAVE BEEN- DONE AND
DEMONSTRATED BY LOCAL AGENCIES-
IN REGARDS TO FUTURE STATES OF
EMERGENCY. AND SO WHAT THIS
LEGISLATION IN PARTICULAR LOCAL
LEGISLATIVE BODIES. WILL NOT
HAVE TO RELY ON AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER AT THE STATE LEVEL. TO
SAFELY CONDUCT THEIR BUSINESS-
TO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES
TO THEIR CONSTITUENTS- AMID
THESE TIMES OF EMERGENCIES LIKE
A DEVASTATING EARTHQUAKE OR A-
WILDFIRE. CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
MAY MAKE IN PERSON MEETINGS
DANGEROUS OR SIMPLY NOT
POSSIBLE. I AM SO INSTEAD THEY
WILL HAVE AN OPTION THEY'LL
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO MEET
REMOTELY WHILE ENSURING. ACCESS
ENGAGEMENT- FOR ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC AND SO AB THREE
SIXTY ONE I WILSHIRE OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT GOVERNMENT. WHEN WE
NEED IT MOST- IN FUTURE TIMES
OF SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTION. I
LIKE WE'VE EXPERIENCED OVER
THIS PAST. FOURTEEN MONTHS AND
SO FOR THESE REASONS MADAM
CHAIR RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY IS MARCUS. DETWILER A
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. THURMOND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HARPER AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IN SUPPORT IS
MARCUS DEPLOYMENT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF. MY
NAME IS A MARKET THAT WHILE
THEY'RE ON THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION-
AB THREE SIXTY ONE IMPLEMENT
THE REASONABLE. COMMONSENSE
TIMELY NARROWLY CRAFTED
PROVISIONS THAT BOTH ALLOW
LOCAL AGENCIES TO BE PUBLICLY
DURING DECLARED LOCAL
EMERGENCIES WHILE ALSO ENSURING
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PUBLIC ACCESS IS PRESERVED. THE
GOVERNOR OF MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
EXECUTIVE ORDER THIRD OF THE
RECOGNITION THAT THE CURRENT
PROVISIONS OF THE BROWN ACT DO
NOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESS
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS WHERE IT
WOULD BE UNSAFE TO CONGREGATE
IN ONE LOCATION. TODAY THE
MERGING STATE WAS THE CORONA
VIRUS PANDEMIC. BUT FUTURE
DISASTERS REMAIN TO BE SEEN WE
CAN HOWEVER BE PREPARED FOR THE
NEXT DISASTER WE THINK NOW OF
THE CITY OF PARADISE AN EXAMPLE
THAT IT THAT. IN THE CITY OF
PARADISE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INCLUDING LOCAL AGENCY BOARD
MEMBERS WERE FORCED TO EVACUATE
THE ENTIRE CITY. MEETING
REMOTELY PURSUANT TO THE TERMS
OF AB THREE SIXTY ONE WOULD BE
ABLE TO HELP IN SITUATIONS LIKE
THE BILL THREE ONE WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL AGENCIES TO CONTINUE TO
MEET PUBLICLY AND PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES WHILE
REMAINING SAFE DURING LIFE
THREATENING EMERGENCIES.
WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AB THREE SIXTY ONE INCLUDE
SAFEGUARDS THAT WERE DEVELOPED
TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THESE MEETINGS IS PRESERVED.
OVERALL IT IS ANTICIPATED THAT
THESE PROVISIONS WILL BE PUT TO
USE ONLY ONCE OR TWICE A YEAR
IF I EVER. OVERALL AND
IMPORTANTLY THE BILL DOES
NOTHING TO WEAKEN THE SPIRIT OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRYING TO WITHIN THE BROWN
ACT. I'D LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR THEIR TIME AND THEIR
CONSIDERATION WITH THE REGARD
TO AB THREE SIXTY ONE I WILL
REMAIN LISTENING IN ON THE LINE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER THAT
WILDER- OPERATOR LET'S SEE READ
DISAPPEARS WE HAVE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE GALLERY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OPERATOR AB THREE FOUR COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN.
ZERO LINE SIXTY FOUR YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. ZACH BUILDING GEHRY
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BLIGNAUT. ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AT JEAN HURTS
CALLING IN TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO.
THANK YOU MA'AM CARE ROCK
BUCKLEY ON BAKER ON BEHALF OF
INTER COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINED UP. ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A CRAZY THOMPSON WITH
THE METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COMING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINEUP. ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
JEFF NEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCITION OF COUNTIES
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBER SERVICE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
STACEY HEATON RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FOUR
NINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN
THIRTY MILLION ON BEHALF OF
MESA WATER DISTRICT SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIND A.
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO. MADAM
CHAIR JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DOWNTOWN
ASSOCIATION WE ARE SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. IN THE
LINE OF ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
BEGAN MARY R. WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
WILL MOVE INTO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO- MRS DEAN
AND MISS FINEMAN. OF JUSTIN ARE
YOU AVAILABLE. YEAH THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRY MEMBERS
CAME WHEN DEAN WHAT LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
AUTHOR STAFF AND SPONSORS OF
THE AMENDMENT TO THE BILL LAST
MONTH WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
RECENT CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S ARCHIVE IN
CONSIDERATION OF A PROPOSED
REVISION. REGRETTABLY WE MUST
OPPOSE. EIGHTY THREE SIX ONE
AND MARKET DEMAND AND- THE GOAL
OF ENSURE THAT POP AGENCIES
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
SERVICES DURING TIMES OF CRISIS
OR EMERGENCY IF MARKLE.
ACCOMMODATIONS MAY TEMPORARILY
BE NEEDED TO ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COMBAT NECESSARY
BUSINESS. EVERYONE LAUGHS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MUST CONNECT THE
PUBLIC'S BUSINESS IS OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER LEADING
FUNDAMENTAL AND LONGSTANDING
PUBLIC PROTECTION SHOULD BE
EXTREMELY RARE AND HIGHLY
CIRCUMSCRIBED. EIGHTY TREE SIX
ONE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY OF A LOCAL
AGENCY CAN MEET USING
TELECONFERENCE TECHNOLOGY
WITHOUT COMPLYING WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BROWN ACT.
UNFORTUNATELY EIGHTY THREE SIX
ONE GOES TOO FAR BY EXEMPTING
ELECTED OFFICIALS FROM THE
OBLIGATION TO IDENTIFY THEIR
TELECONFERENCE LOCATION. EXCEPT
IN EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES THE
REQUIREMENT FOR TELECONFERENCE
LOCATION SHOULD BE ACCEPTABLE
TO THE PUBLIC SHOULD REMAIN IN
PLACE. ALTHOUGH A QUORUM OF
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATIVE BODY
SHOULD PARTICIPATE WITHIN THE
GEOGRAPHICAL BACKED BY
GEOGRAPHIC BOUNDARIES OF THE
BODY'S JURISDICTION. UNDER
EIGHTY THREE SIX ONE THE
PREDICATE FOR EXEMPTIONS TO
THIS REQUIREMENT IS TOO LAX. IN
ADDITION THE BILL SHOULD BE
AMENDED TO REQUIRE MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY TO APPEAR
ON VIDEO DURING PUBLIC MEETINGS
WHENEVER TELECONFERENCING FROM
THE PRIVATE LOCATION. IT
CONCERNS THE PUBLIC WOULD HAVE
NO IDEA WHO MIGHT BE IN THE
ROOM THE LEGISLATORS INCLUDING
LOBBYIST OTHER REPRESENTATIVE
OTHER PRIVATE INSURANCE.
CONSTITUENTS HAVE A RIGHT TO
VIEW THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS
ACTING MAKE DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT THEM. FURTHERMORE DIRECT
ACCESS TO ELECTED OFFICIALS IS
THE CORNERSTONE OF A HEALTHY
DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY. REQUIRING
AN INTERNET BASED SERVICE OR A
CALL AN OPTION IT INSUFFICIENT
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SHOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE BOTH TO THE
PUBLIC. THIS ENSURES THAT
PEOPLE WITH AN UNSTABLE
INTERNET CONNECTION OR NO
ACCESS TO INTERNET ARE STILL
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE AND ALLOW
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
ATTRACT THE REPRESENTATIVE ON
VIDEO. THE CURRENT IS REMINDED
OF HOW FRAGILE A FUNCTIONAL
GOVERNMENT IS ALL OF OUR WELL
BEING. WE SHOULD BE EMBRACING
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS MADE IT
EASY FOR PEOPLE TO STAY
CONNECTED DURING HIGH. THE
PUBLIC ACCESSIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BROWN ACT
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
CAN ATTEND MEETINGS IN PERSON
IN CAN DIRECTLY ADDRESSED
MEMBERS OF GOVERNING BODY.
BROADLY REMOVING ITS ABILITY IS
CONTRARY TO THE BASIC TENANTS
THE REPRESENTATIVE ACROSS THE-
B. HAPPENED. CALIFORNIA ACTION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE
NO ON AB THREE SIX ONE TODAY
AND NOT KEEPING MANDATE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
NEXT WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
YEAH I THINK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS OLIVIA STAGNANT AND I'M
THINKING GAUGE WENT COORDINATOR
BUT LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY. I
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
THAT ADVOCATES FOR EQUITABLE
POLICIES EQUAL ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITY ALONGSIDE WORLD
COMMUNITIES ACROSS. THE SAN
JOAQUIN IN EASTERN COACHELLA
VALLEY. WE ARE GRATEFUL TO THE
AUTHOR STAFF AND SPONSORS FOR
THE AMENDMENTS MADE LAST MONTH.
BUT WE REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT
THE WAYS IN WHICH EIGHTY THREE
SIX HUNDRED NEGATIVELY IMPACT
THE COMMUNITIES THEY WORK WITH
THAT WE MUST REGRETFULLY
OPPOSED AB THREE SIX ONE AND
LEFT IT AT MY DAD. I THERE ARE
SOMETIMES FAITH ACTORS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT YOU CAN EASILY
MANIPULATE THE PROVISIONS THAT
EIGHTY THREE SIX ONE AND
CONFIDENCE A LOT IN ORDER TO
LIMIT PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
GOVERNMENTAL DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. NOT PARTICULARLY XIN
IN THE PAST YEAR WE'VE SEEN HOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE YOU SEE AN ABILITY
TO MEET IN PERSON TO LIMIT THE
PUBLIC AND CUT. SAMPLE ANAHEIM
CITY COUNCIL LIMITED PUBLIC
COMMENT ON AN UNPOPULAR GOP
UNTIL EIGHT AM. SIMILARLY THE
FACT THAT- COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS MAKE DECISIONS TO
ELIMINATE A COLD TESTING SITE
IN THE SMALL COMMUNITY OF TOWN
TO A CREEK. WITHOUT INPUT FROM
RESIDENTS. WELL THE REASON
AMENDMENT IN PERFECT FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT WE STILL REMAIN
CONCERNED WITH EIGHTY THREE SIX
ONE FAILURE TO BE DEFINED
TELECONFERENCE TO ENSURE THAT
LEGISLATIVE BODIES MUST MEET ON
CAMERA AND TO PROVIDE. INTERNET
SERVICE IN CALLING OPTIONS TO
THE PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE WHEN
HE DID NOT THINK TO MEET IN
PERSON. ADDITIONALLY THE
DEFINITION OF EMERGENCY IS WAY
TOO BROAD AND COULD EASILY BE
ABUSED BY ELECTED OFFICIALS.
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
RATIFY AMERICANS SITUATION
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS AND
APPLYING THE SAME PROVISION ALL
TYPES OF EMERGENCIES. IF
INDIVIDUAL A LECTIN OFFICIALS
TOO MUCH POWER OVER PUBLIC
ACCESS AND LACK NUANCE. IN A
WILDFIRE EVACUATION FOR EXAMPLE
IT IS STILL POSSIBLE TO REQUIRE
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO BE
PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE TO THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT. AB THREE SIX
ONE SHOULD BE TAILORED TO
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES AND
SHOULD ONLY ALLOW AUTHORIZED
PUBLIC HEALTH AUTHORITIES TO
DECLARE EMERGENCY. SITUATIONS
THAT LIMIT PUBLIC ACCESS. AB
THREE ONE DEFICIENT VEGAN THAT
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MAKE THEM THESE MODIFICATIONS
OF THE BROWN ACT UNDER TEN U.
S. SECOND GET THAT. OF COURSE
IN MANY INSTANCES ANY TENUOUSLY
DECLARED EMERGENCY COULD LIKELY
BE REGARD FOR THE LAW. BUT NOT
ALL COMMUNITIES HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO LITIGATE. FRANKLY
THE IDEA THAT THE OWNERS SHOULD
BE ON PRIVATE SECTOR ACTORS TO
HOLD GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE
RATHER THAN CREATING PUBLIC
SAFEGUARDS AGAINST CORRUPTION
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
FUNDAMENTALLY MISUNDERSTANDS.
THE ROLE OF GOVERNMENT IN OUR
SOCIETY. BECAUSE AB THREE ONE
DOES NOT DO ENOUGH TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC FROM ABUSE WE MUST
OPPOSE IT AND LEFT MANAGED TO
SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS THEY'RE
MADE. AS IT IS WRITTEN OUT AB
THREE SIX ONE PROVISIONS COULD
EASILY EVEN IF EVEN IF YOU
WANTED TO LIMIT PUBLIC ACCESS.
FURTHERING THE MARGINALIZATION
OF COMMUNITIES WHO ALREADY FACE
MANY BARRIERS TO PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY NO I
SEE NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE
VIBRATOR. FOR IN OPPOSITION TO
A. B. THREE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE OF THEM ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE- WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM US SOME MEMBER ALMOST IN A
SECOND BY THREE OF US. DID YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIVEAU MANAGER. THANK YOU
SOMEONE MEMBER FIRST I WANT TO
THANK YOU IN YOUR SPONSOR FOR
STARTING YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL
LAST YEAR. I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND EFFORT
YOU AND THE SPONSOR MADE TO
ENGAGE WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
EARLY AND OFTEN. THURMOND THE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED BEFORE
COMMITTEE SHOW YOUR SENSITIVITY
TO THE PERSPECTIVES OF ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. THIS KIND
OF DELIBERATE OF IN
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS WE SHOULD
ALL AIM FOR ESPECIALLY WHEN
MAKING CHANGES TO THE BROWN AT.
THE CENTERPIECE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. OPEN MEETING LAW
THAT IMPACTS EVERYONE OF OUR
CONSTANT FUNDS CONSTITUENTS.
LOOK AT IT LET ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND INTEREST GROUPS.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENT WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION BY THE PUBLIC IN
THE PROCEEDINGS OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THIS BILL IS A
RESPONSIBLE TARGETED SOLUTION
TO MAKE PERMANENT TOOLS WE
UTILIZE DURING CIRCUMSTANCES.
MOST OF US NEVER IMAGINED
BEFORE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY. I
AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED SECRETARY PLEASE%
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY IRAQI VOTING. THAT
HE. NOT VOTING BLOOM. I BURGER
FOR. BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS
WELL I LOSE RIVAS THREE OF US I
LEE LET'S COVER RIVERSIDE.
WITHOUT ARE YOU SEVEN ZERO OKAY
JEWELERS HEALTH ZERO. MA'AM WE
HAVE TO SPEND WITH THE CHEN
ITEMS THIS. I REALLY DID THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOING ITS PART
ME CONSENT OKAY WHAT DO CONSENT
FIRST SHE'S BEEN. THE SECOND.
YOUR MOTION THE SECOND SORRY
I'M WRONG ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER LUCKY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
HAI LACKEY LACKEY ADD BLOOM
BLOOM I BURGER HARD THAT HI
REMEMBER THAT ARE ALMOST.
ALMOST AYE THREE OF US
THREE OF US R. ROBERT RIVAS.
OVER RIVERSIDE HOTEL. OUR I
EIGHT ZERO OKAY CONSIDER EIGHT
ZERO OUT. OKAY WE'VE DISPENSED
WITH AGENDA ITEMS FOR THIS
HEARING WILL BE LEAVING THE
ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON
PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS FOR
BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL OR NEED
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. YEAH OF. ARE
AB. SIX THIRTY FOUR. CLINTON
GOOD WITH ROBBERY ROBERT REED
ALL RIGHT. AND THAT IS TWO. SIX
THE BILL AND THAT IS OUT THE
WHAT WAS THE FORGET THE NUMBER
SORRY AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR THE
LOTUS SEVEN ZERO ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS SIDE. EIGHT ZERO
I'M BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO. AB
NINE SEVEN DAYS A VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO THREE OF US. THREE OF US
SIDE THE VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO AB.
NINE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT ZERO. AB
THREE SIXTY ONE THE VOTE IS
SEVEN UP THAT ONE'S FINE. THE
MISSING ONE. EIGHT THIRTY TO
SEVENTY HOLD ON ONCE OFF.
BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE NINE
SEVEN YEAH. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY- I DID GET SHE DID THEY
DID THAT ONE WE'RE DONE. I
THINK IT'S EIGHT THIRTY TWO
WERE MISSING. AB. EIGHT THIRTY
TWO. YES BOERNER HORVATH
BURKHARDT THAT I USE RIVAS THIS
WITH A SIGH. OKAY WE HAVE
EVERYTHING LET'S SEE. WE'RE
GOOD OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WANT TO THANK OUR
COMMITTEE BEHIND THE SCENES
HERE WORKING HARD ON ALL THESE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WORK THIS
YEAR IN THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.